que je l'évoquais ce matin alors que
dans d'autres pays la réponse à la crise
à est incarné par un personnage
politique un médecin ou un chercheur qui
a réussi à entraîner la population
derrière ces recommandations nous avons
assisté en france à des propos
discordants qui ont beaucoup nui au
niveau de confiance de la population
à propos d'un virus inconnu les attentes
dans la science était très élevé certes
la controverse est normale elle fait
avancer la science
mais quand elle s'étale aussi largement
dans les médias elle fait plutôt
augmenter le niveau d'inquiétude
nous avions donc souhaité demander des
explications aux scientifiques comme
certains n'ont pas manqué de nous le
rappeler mais nous ne lire nous
n'aurions pas nous ne sommes pas des
scientifiques de haut niveau mais ce
n'est pas une conversation scientifique
cen'est pas à une conversation
scientifiques que nous convions nos
intervenants nous représentons des
personnes qui dans leur immense majorité
ne le sont pas davantage c'est pourquoi
nous aurions préféré préféré éviter les
monologues sans contradictoires
toutefois ainsi que vous l'avez rappelé
lors de votre audition à l'assemblée
professeur à propos du conseil
scientifique
vous n'êtes pas arriver à vous parler et
il nous est apparu que vous ne
parviendrez pas davantage dans cette
enceinte à parler en toute sérénité
cette audition a pour objet la recherche
les tests et les traitements elle
abordera notamment la méthodologie
applicable aux essais cliniques
les orientations privilégiées en france
au vu de la comparaison entre discovery
et recovery les résultats ci que la
question des publications ou d annonce
précoce dans la crise
donc je vais demander aux professeurs
out de présenter brièvement ses
principaux messages en 10 15 minutes
parce que les messages sont importants
et vous ne manquerez pas bien sûr de
nous alimenter par voie écrite comme
vous l'avait déjà fait à différentes
occasions je demanderai ensuite
chacun des des rapporteurs d'intervenir
et ensuite ce seront nos les questions
de nos commissaires que nous regroupons
voilà alors avant c'est une commission
denquête donc je vais procéder à la
demande de deux prêté serment rappeler
que tout propos mensongers et punis
d'une peine pouvant aller jusqu'à cinq
ans d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amendé
donc professeur didier raoult est prêté
serment de dire la vérité rien que la
vérité levé la main droite et dit je le
jure je je merci bonjour appelle bien
sûr comme à chaque fois il est de mon
devoir que le port du masque est
obligatoire
je vous demande la plus grande vigilance
par le pour le garder tout au long des
heures de ses auditions de cet après
midi
merci donc sans plus tarder écoutez je
vous cède la parole
je vous remercie et d'ailleurs je
voudrais profiter de cette offre merci
de la magie tu es ici de cette occasion
dans lequel vous m'avez demandé de juré
de dire toute la vérité vous expliquer
pourquoi je ne peux pas me retrouver à
discuter avec des gens qui font une
tribune en disant que je frotte dès que
je triche en mettant leurs noms et
ensuite faire une discussion avec ya une
limite c'est plus des discussions
scientifiques en a d'autres qui ont
porté plainte auprès de moi auprès du
conseil de l'ordre et vous comprendrez
bien que mal limite c'est une des
limites à la convivialité
je n'aime pas qu'on insulte je n'aime
pas qu'on porte plainte contre moi a
qu'à prendre demande de débattre en
toute sérénité
je le fais pas et donc je vous le dis
très solennellement et après avoir juré
de dire la vérité je n'ai jamais fraudé
de ma vie j'ai écrit 3500 publications
internationales
je n'en ai jamais rétracté aucune alors
bien entendu sur 3500 il y a eu des
erreurs qui sont passés pour l'instant
il ya une fille qui me traquent la une
chasseuse de têtes depuis que je suis
célèbre qui a réussi à trouver cinq
erreurs sur 3500 il y en a probablement
beaucoup plus que ça j'estime qu'il ya
entre 2 et 4 % d'erreurs dans les
papiers que j'ai fait
donc je ne serais pas étonné qu'on
trouve d'autres erreurs mais je dois
vous dire que je ne suis qu'un pauvre
main que je fais des erreurs comme tout
le monde mais de m'accuser sur une
tribune officiellement de fraude de
mettre son nom là dessus et de penser
que je vais débattre avec c'est au
dessus de mes forces et je vous demande
de me pardonner de ne pas avoir la force
de discuter sereinement avec des gens
qui m'insultent je ferai pas je ferai
jamais bien si vous si j'ai quelques
messages à passer dans cette affaire
c'est effectivement si vous voulez la
chose qui me frappe le plus depuis le
début et qui est lié au fait qu'il
manque quelque chose dans mon la forme
de mon cerveau je suis absolument
incapable de mesurer la dimension
symbolique des choses c'est pas ce qui
s'est passé n'est pas normal c'est on
n'est plus en train de parler de chimie
ou de malades ou de médicaments on est
en train de parler de quelque chose qui
est déconnecté de ce que moi je connais
moi je suis un être très pragmatique et
pratique il ya toujours eu dans la
séance une grande différence entre
l'empirisme d'un côté c'est à dire
l'observation des phénomènes et leur
description si vous voulez d'autres tard
les théories déductive et spéculative
donc donc dont je ne suis pas un
praticien d'accord mais si vous voulez
ce qui s'est passé dans cette situation
est absolument inouïe pour moi et pas
que pour moi ça marquera tout
l'épistémologie l'histoire des sciences
c'est à dire que un des deux médicaments
les plus prescrits au monde ait pu être
considéré comme étant un truc qui tue et
10 % des gens est quelque chose qui
montre qu'il y avait une déconnexion
entre la perception de ce qui est
l'hydrochlorothiazide si vous voulez de
la chimie de la molécule qui a été
utilisée c'est probablement deux
milliards de personnes
donc il ya quelque chose que je ne
comprends pas auquel je ne suis pas si
c'est pas maintenant je me rends compte
que je comprends pas bien les données
symbolique si vous voulez c'est comme ça
et donc je suis extraordinairement
surprise l'ampleur qu'a pris cette chose
est immédiatement c'est à dire dès que
mon premier papier
a été envoyée la chasseuse de têtes l'a
fait dire que j'avais des conflits
d'intérêts avec sanofi ce qui est
complètement idiot je fais des essais
thérapeutiques pour personne ça fait 25
ans que je contrains vous fait pas la
deuxième chose est la demande
elle a fait de confirmer elle nous a
fait faire envoyer au journal qui
menaçait de le d'enlever cet article qui
est devenu le plus cité de toute la
littérature soit la thérapeutique du coc
u19 city cité de 1400 fois en dix ans
que je n'avais pas eu les autorisations
ge a pas eu de cdp et la troisième chose
déluge des gens qui sont des maniaques
de méthodologie je ne pouvais pas
imaginer qu'en envoyant un papier comme
ça comme j'en ai envoyé tellement dans
ma vie si vous voulez ceux ci allaient
faire une espèce de folie mondiale et
donc toutes les explications qu'on
pourra donner sont pas inintéressantes
c'est le temps qui trahira pour
comprendre ce qui s'est passé
moi personnellement je ne comprends pas
c'est que ça ne fait pas partie de ce
que je suis capable de comprendre parce
que qui me manque une case sur la
signification symbolique des choses
peut-être pas que symbolique mais en
tout cas c'est pas mon c'est pas mon
problème donc nous on a continué à faire
je pensais depuis longtemps
en réalité depuis plus de vingt ans je
pensais qu'il fallait faire comme pour
les centres anticancéreux des centres de
lutte pour les maladies infectieuses qui
comprenait tous les patients le
laboratoire la recherche
petit à petit je les écris à 20 ans
quand j'étais le conseiller de de mattei
et de madame haigneré où j'ai rencontré
d'ailleurs gilles bloch donc y
connaissez parfaitement mes projets
puisqu'il n'est entré au cabinet de
maintenant il est directeur leader il
était rentré au cabinet mal amélioré en
dix ans pour faire face à des situations
comme celle-là il faut avoir des
structures organisées dans lequel on
fasse tout dentelle y ait des gens qui
soient compétents à tous les nobel et à
tous les niveaux de manière à pouvoir
répondre toutes les questions au fur et
à mesure et pas avoir un ordre dispersé
donc l' ordre dispersé monsieur le
sénateur je savais qu'il allait arriver
c'est pas moi qui les disperser nous
étions en ordre dispersé et d'une
manière très singulière pour pas que
vous croyez que je considère
qu'à paris plus rien est organisée c'est
pas vrai en neurologie si quelqu'un
avait un problème dans ma famille je
l'enverrai la pitié parce qu'il ya un
centre de neurologique et qu'on sache
s'il y avait quelqu'un qui est un
problème génétique je l'enverrai
sûrement à necker et imaginez pas de
problème avec ça mais en maladies
infectieuses
ici on a détruit l'organisation des
maladies infectieuses
elle n'existe plus et donc si vous
retrouvez avec un port marseillais en
train de vous dire ce qu'ils pensent
c'est parce qu'il ya une destruction
physique de l'organisation des maladies
infectieuses qui était à l'hôpital
claude bernard là les forces de maladies
infectieuses l'institut de veille
sanitaire a été mis à saint maurice
alors que c'était une vraie bonne idée
j'avais écrit à l'époque de le mettre à
côté de pasteur ou de maître - des
antennes de pasteur à côté voyez le les
hôpitaux de maldic spécialisé en
maladies infectieuses ont été dispersées
dans toute la ville et donc vous n'avez
pas de cendres vous n'avez pas de
pardonnez moi je vieillis vous n'avez
pas de patron et si de maladies
infectieuses voulait pas alors que vous
l'aviez ya 30 ans vous l'avez pas vous
avez des patrons dans les autres
domaines vous avez des gens qui sont des
leaders dans les autres domaines
dans ce domaine là vous n'avez pas de
leader vous n'avez plus de leaders
microbiologie celui qui était le
meilleur a été tellement dégoûté celui
qui est parti en suisse
d'accord donc vous avez il ya un
problème ici avec les maladies
infectieuses
un véritable problème d'évolution l'asie
placer qui fait des choses absolument
remarquable s'est éloigné et petit à
petit avec le temps de la pratique des
maladies infectieuses à l'hôpital
pasteur donc quand j'étais jeune on
faisait tous les diagnostics l'institut
pasteur l'épidémiologie partout à la
situe passerelle à petit à petit cette
partie là a disparu pour être remplacé
par par des parrains une recherche
fondamentale beaucoup en neurosciences
sont parmi les meilleurs du monde
donc je ne vais pas une critique de la
qualité de ce qui se passe
il ya une désorganisation et une
désorganisation de ce pays et qui se
voit ici pour ce sujet je dis pas que
c'est vrai pour d'autres
si je trouve que bell pour la
microchirurgie je pense que j'en
strasbourg sont les meilleurs c'est ce
que je pense mais globalement c'est ce
que je perçois j'ai toujours pensé que
je pas la chirurgie cardiaque à paris et
merveilleuse et elle continue à la
georges pompidou
ces pages il y a un problème
d'organisation de fonds et celui des
maladies infectieuses vous savez que de
gaulle avait répondu à la cancérologie
en disant écoutez on va faire des
centres anticancéreux donc qui regroupe
à la fois la radiothérapie la
chimiothérapie la chirurgie la médecine
il marche de manière inégale mais ils
ont joué un rôle très important
là aussi en cancérologie l'institut
gustave roussy une chose extraordinaire
c'est un des meilleurs centres au monde
d'immunologie de cancérologie donc sais
c'est pas la question
la question c'est que ce domaine n'est
pas organisé et que donc il ne peut
connaître des discordances moi j'ai
proposé de faire créer cette centre de
la nature de celui que j'ai fini par
réussir à construire à marseille dans le
pays de manière à mailler le pays pour
pouvoir faire face à des crises
sanitaires qui n'arrêteront pas et notre
susceptibilité dans notre civilisation
aux crises sanitaires est très très
importante très très vive elle peut
désorganiser complètement la société si
nous ne sommes pas armés pour lutter
contre ces cellules sanitaire voilà donc
le sens général parce que je voulais
dire et puis ensuite on rentre dans le
détail de ce que vous voudrez t merci
pour cette représentation de
l'infectiologie en france donc nous
allons rentrer dans le vif du sujet je
passe parole à catherine des roches
merci monsieur le président pensait pas
que les questions agressives
j'en fais tomber mon chevalet
donc merci au professeur raoul de nous
avoir déjà donné des réponses à nos
questions très en amont pour nous les
rapporteurs de de cette audition ce qui
a permis de de travail et les réponses
et est aussi de pouvoir compléter
puisqu'on avait fait une audition dans
le cadre des commissions des affaires
sociales que je pilotais comme
rapporteur de la branche maladie où nous
avions entendu des gens n'ont pas en
public mais où nous avions déjà balayé
un peu déçu j'aime qui correspondait
l'état de la situation
au mois de mai quand nous l'avions nous
l'avions fait moi j'avais plusieurs
questions la première qui est plus
d'ordre pratico pratique c'est celle du
parcours du patient
qu'est-ce qui depuis le début de la
l'évolution de l'épidémie
comment est-elle parcours du patient en
février ou au début vous avez vu arriver
les premiers patients dans votre
institut
quelle est-elle parcours du patient test
traitement isolement est ce qu'il s'est
modifiée au fil du temps et qu'elle est
aujourd'hui le parcours d'un patient qui
vient qui vient vous consulté à
l'institut un institut marseillais le
deuxième point c'est c'est quelque chose
que j'ai posée
déjà ce matin au professeur delfraissy
même si luis nenê venu en fonction que
le 11 mars mais lorsque fin janvier la
ministre de la santé nous dit au vu de
vraisemblablement de modélisation de
l'inserm
il ya peu de risque que le virus arrive
arrive chez nous bon professeur de
français nous a dit qu'à l'époque il
s'intéresse à mon sujet mais que en
effet dès la mi-février lui même avait
avait senti quelque chose se passait
quel est votre avis sur cette ces
modélisations qu'on peut faire dire cela
la ministre de la santé de l'époque
comment l'inserm a travaillé pour
arriver à ces conclusions si ce sont ces
conclusions qui ont été à l'origine de
de la vie et vous comment au niveau de
votre institut et de votre habitude de
ces maladies infectieuses même si là on
était sur un nouveau virus vous quels
étaient les alertes que vous aviez sur
quoi vous basez pour pour avoir
à voir ce degré de connaissance
qu'apparemment les autorités n'avaient
pas ça c'est le premier point
la deuxième question c'est sur les les
essais cliniques
c'est une question que j'ai évoqué ce
matin avec le professeur delfraissy
également c'était dans ces périodes de
crise sanitaire où les équipes
soignantes voit arriver des patients bon
pour certains en consultation mais pour
d'autres en réanimation ou en
hospitalisation et où il ya le besoin
d'apporter une réponse rapide et
thérapeutique aux malades
comment peut se concilier avec cette
exigence d'essais randomisés de travaux
scientifiques robuste pour voir
l'efficacité du traitement
mais s'il n'y a pas pour tous ces
patients qui ne rentreraient pas dans
les études ou dans les essais avec un
médicament testé
est-ce qu'il ya pas une perte de chance
pour tous ceux qui ne rentrent pas
danser dans ces cases là bon vous nous
avez dans la note
donnez votre avis un peu sur ces essais
les essais randomisés tels qu'ils sont
et pas forcément adapté à la situation
pandémique telle qu'elle était donc
j'aimerais aussi vous entendre dessus
une question plus que plus large qui est
peut-être pas celles centrées sur la
commission denquête mais qui nous
intéresse au sein des commissions des
affaires sociales puisqu'on avait fait
un rapport sur l'accès à l'innovation et
notamment sur les essais cliniques
le comité de protection des personnes et
j'aimerais avoir votre toute façon assez
rapide
votre avis en effet ce que vous nous
avez dit un peu dans la note mais
résumer sur comment vous voyez-vous les
comités de protection des personnes qui
étaient au départ de protée des comités
de protection des personnes éthiques
et qu'est ce qui a pu faire que là on
est allé assez vite sur certains essais
et que et qu'habituellement on n'y
arrive pas merci vous répondait
directement professeur à chacun chacune
des rapporteurs sur le bouton rouge
voilà c'est la manière dont nous
travaillons
soul et comme je voulais dit je ne suis
pas un homme de spéculations donc je
suis très empirique est très pratique
pragmatique c'est ma nature
elle me réserve de très bonnes surprises
je serais content de ce qu'on a pu
trouver je pense que l'on peut découvrir
d'ailleurs que par l'observation et
l'empirisme où on peut confirmer par les
techniques méthodologiques mais on peut
pas découvrir comme ça ça fait l'objet
de grands grands débats épistémologiques
donc la manière dont nous travaillons
d'abord c'est que nous lisons toute la
littérature et donc si vous voulez moi
j'ai été frappée du fait si vous voyez
le staff que nous avons donc il ya une
vingtaine de gens qui sont au niveau
professeurs ou juste en dessous c'est
travailler ensemble chacun avec beaucoup
de domaines c'est pour ça que je crois
ce que j'appelle les mid recherche et
non pas au réseau je crois au nil
recherche et on se voit tous les jours
tous les jours tous les joueurs à 8
heures du matin et on a un pharmacien
qui nous fait vous avez vu vous voyez
les applications de la mm
qu'est ce qui est vraiment est ce que
vraiment on applique là et même quand on
est médecin et la réponse c'est non
deuxièmement on a une spécialiste
d'hématologie co-régulation tiff et
bibliographie des de stomatologie
co-régulation on a un super immunologie
ce qui était un ancien directeur des
sciences de la vie du cnrs qui fouillent
vraiment au niveau moléculaire sur la
physiopathologie on a un chimiste
bien sûr on a des infectiologues
virologues des microbiologistes et
chacun nous des épidémiologistes de très
très haut niveau dont celui qui a fait
toutes les enquêtes sont charles de
gaulle dont je reparlerai qui font un
travail de fond sur le suivi permanent
de la bibliographie sur ces domaines et
à chaque fois qu'on a une question
quelqu'un creuse comme un fou pour en
tirer quelque chose ce qui veut dire je
vous en ai déjà dit ce qu'on a déjà fait
54 publications internationales qui sont
ou publier ou accepter ou en prêt trink
donc quand on s'est retrouvé face à
cette situation on a fait comme
d'habitude c'est à dire qu'on a lu tout
ce qu'avait fait les seuls sachant
qu'ils étaient chinois et on a regardé
mais qu'est ce qu'ils font et qu'est ce
qu'ils disent
et puis on a regardé qu'est ce qui se
passe avec les autres coronavirus et
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec le
premier épisode de sa et au début moi je
vous assure j'ai téléphoné tout de suite
au ministère pour dire écoutez voilà les
médicaments qui marche sur le sar ce vin
pourquoi regarde pas le cargo side qui
est un anti staphylococcique qui est
générique et qui coûtent rien qui a été
utilisé dans le cers un en corée qui a
même il ya même eu un brevet un moment
qui a été déposé pour le traitement du
sahara avec ça deuxièmement la
chloroquine qui avait été montée je
rappelle qu'il faut si maintenant on
revient en arrière mais à l'époque il
est le traitement du sart c'est la
chloroquine hydroxyque l'anguille et
donc les premiers résultats qui sont
venues de chine
in vitro a publié nordin un des articles
du groupe de journaux celles ci sont
très bons journaux c'était écouter les
deux médicaments qui marche et la
chloroquine et auxi chloroquine d'une
part et d'autre part leur m d'ici d'hier
qui lui n'était pas disponible sauf
avoir des accords avec gilead ou à
travailler sur des essais dans le cadre
de ce que voulait faire gilad que nous
voulions pas faire donc nous peu de
temps après les chinois ont commencé à
dire écoutez on a de manière
préliminaire nos premiers résultats il
ya 100 malades qu'on a traitées on voit
une amélioration clinique radiologique
et sur le portage virale c'est ça qu'on
a fait c'est à dire qu'on si vous voulez
le lead et on vous dira le risque de
certains mais l'idée que les choses vont
se dérouler en france ces cds qui n'a
pas lieu
c'est une pandémie ça se déroule partout
il ya tout le monde a une expérience
tout le monde a quelque chose à dire et
donc on doit regarder les premiers qui
ont subi le flux pour voir déjà il avait
décrit une quantité de choses dont nous
y compris des choses qu'on a découvert
un peu plus tardivement comme parce que
ce qu'ils appelaient les hypoxie
heureuse c'est à dire le fait que
y'avait pas les signes respiratoires
qu'on a d'habitude dans les pneumonies
et donc ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que dès qu'on a eu
des cas on s'est mis à d'abord tout de
suite et je réponds à quelqu'un qui me
demander pourquoi il ya une telle
l'at-elle délais dans la mise en place
des tests nous les tests dès que le
génome a été publié trois jours appelé
avons commandé les amorces pc donc
l'idée une des raisons du retard c'est
qu'il y avait je sais que j'ai eu
l'occasion d'expliquer assemblée
nationale c'est qu'il y avait dans
l'esprit des gens du ministère qu'il y
avait des centres nationaux de référence
quitte ce qui est un rêve parce qu'il
peut pas y avoir un centre national de
référence pour le mahdi qui n'existe pas
donc c'est pas possible pas de samba sur
une référence et des gens qu'ils et moi
je suis un no money les gens qui
faisaient les coronavirus c'est pas du
tout d'ailleurs c'est quelqu'un qui est
à caen d'accord donc c'est les gens se
sont dit mais c'est nous les centres
nationaux de référence est donc au début
moi j'ai vu ces discussions on me disait
écouter non mais il faut les du cas
positifs faut que vous les envoyer au
centre national de référence mais tout
le monde avait que des séquences sont là
on avait le génome qui est publié
chinois trois jours après et nous on
avait commandé les les allemandes qui va
extrêmement vite et brillantissime
hambourg à a tout de suite dit tout et
voilà moi j'ai testé une qpcr donc on
avait nous sélectionné trois gènes qu'on
avait commandé pour qu'elle en avait
commandé les témoins positif de on a
commandé les deux des allemands et puis
ensuite quand pasteur à présent étudier
ça on april et c'est en a pris tout ce
qui existe et puis on va tester on a
regardé ce qui est bien d'ailleurs pas
ce que tu entends avec la paix c'est
peut-être une question qui reviendra
parfois il ya des contaminations qui se
font à la pcr il faut toujours avoir une
deuxième cache est une troisième pour
être sûr de confirmer les cas qui sont
positifs pour pas raconter des choses
qui sont fausses
parce que il n'ya pas de laboratoire
dans lequel ça n'arrive pas qu'il ya une
contamination
c'est pas vrai ap cr c'est comme ça donc
si vous voulez le la manière dont nous
avons réagi nous si on regarde ce que
fait tout le monde on fait je m'excuse
de cet anglicisme du match marking c'est
à dire qu'on regarde ce qu'ils savent
faire
on fait pareil en les imitent mais c'est
comme ça que que la séance avance 9 fois
sur 10 bases de vie à imiter ceux qui
ont lu la première expérience on fait
pareil donc on a au début on a fait
pareil très rapidement fait rapidement
on a vu qu'on n'était pas sur la même
longueur d'onde parce que chaque fois
qu'on parlait de cette maladie on nous
parlait décès
et de et de cpp d'en savoir s'il fallait
les gens qui étaient contagieux le
remettre à leur faire un prélèvement
rhinopharyngé quand tombé des nues
qu'est ce que vous nous raconter c'est
les gens ils sont revenus pour savoir
s'il avait ça on va pas la faire signe à
taper leur disons qu'ils sont d'accord
pour qu'on les tests pour savoir s'ils
ont le virus
soyez donc on n'était pas ben depuis le
début on n'est pas branché sur la même
voie il ya quelque chose qui m'échappe
je suis pas branché c'était et donc je
les voyais pas comme des sujets décès je
vous le dis probable est donc que je les
vois toujours pas comme des sujets décès
et j'ai suivi au fur et à mesure qu'il y
avait des données qui arrive et on les a
suivis
le premier patient qu'on a eu le
deuxième arrêté c'est sa femme qui était
la première est le premier patient qu'on
a eu et était quelqu'un qui qui nous a
qui nous a parlé de son anneau demi si
vous voulez un sujet sur lequel ont
travaillé pour essayer d'identifier
quelles étaient les causes d'infections
respiratoires y être un virus qui est
parent fleurs et 3 qui donne des anneaux
demi au printemps de la nauze
missionnaire c'est par un flanc et trois
donc ça nous intéresse
l'anneau demi donc on a repéré la dose
minime et si vous ne la cherchez pas et
maintenant on sait qu'il ya 60% des gens
mais les gens n'ont pas observé ça donc
cette phase d'observations empiriques et
de lecture de la delà de la littérature
vous voyez bien que dans les faits
discovery jeu comme ça je ne parle pas
afin de de pardon recovery des anglais
je dis pas du mal de français ils n'ont
pas mis ce critère clinique en disant on
peut faire du diagnostic clinique d'une
maladie infectieuse qui est pas frais il
faut faire des tests biologiques et donc
ils ont publié ça donc il ya quand même
des gens qui ont publié des séries qui
servent actuellement à réfléchir chez
des gens qui n'ont pas eu de
confirmation diagnostic et même
l'élément clinique le plus déterminant
de tous il le connaissait pas qui était
la nauze me aggasy d'accord ça a été
connue ultérieurement et nous je vous
assure vous fait un tri avec la noce mis
en musique il était incroyablement
fonctionnel ça marche très très bien on
l'a testé après en particulier en a
testé dans le dans le personnel de soins
si vous voulez et là on a pu les
interroger avant de savoir s'il avait
été contaminée par donc il ya une vraie
contrainte
ça marche très très bien pour les gens
quant au moins de 60 ans et un test
merveilleux de d'efficacité donc voilà
ce qu'on a fait et au fur à mesure que
le savoir s'est accumulée bien entendu
on a changé
on s'est rendu compte au bout d'un
certain moment qui avait pas ce que
c'était mal décrit au départ thierry les
troubles de la coagulation très
important on a commencé c'est d'abord
les réanimateurs qui n'ont vu puis
ensuite nous on s'est rapidement mis à
anti coaguler les gens quand on s'est
rendu compte que les marqueurs de la
coagulation étaient des marqueurs de
pronostics extrêmement important après
il ya eu les premiers travaux qui sont
sortis de chine encore sur les autopsies
qui montrait que ce qu'on prenait
souvent pour des pneus open peut être
des pneumonies en réalité c'était
embolie pulmonaire multiples et que
c'était des lésions d'infarctus du
poumon et non pas de pneumonie
ce que l'on voyait les chinois avaient
publié aussi qu'il fallait faire des des
scanners low dose sur lequel je me suis
déjà prononcé je pense qu'on a beaucoup
de retard
ça fait partie des projets du nouveau
gouvernement de d'acheter d'augmenter de
l'équipement on a besoin de plus
beaucoup plus de scanner un
sous-équipement absolument terrible dans
ce pays de scanners pour remplacer les
adultes par les scanners low dose à
terme les chinois avaient publié que il
y avait au moins la moitié des gens qui
étaient dix à symptomatique ce qui est
une erreur c'est à dire sans signes
cliniques identifiable en particulier
respiratoires
si vous voulez qu'il y avait des lésions
pulmonaires au scanner on a confirmé sa
d'accord donc ça veut dire bien sûr la
prise en charge à 100 arrêt changé
puisque quand vous avez des gens qui
disent qu'il faut tester les gens
asymptomatiques mais asymptomatiques
savez de quel point de vue est ce que ca
symptomatique que parce que vous les
gens ne sont pas essoufflé apparemment
ou est ce que vous regardez la
saturation en oxygène ce qu'on fait
systématiquement est ce que vous
regardez les scanners et donc vous ne
voyez pas la même chose bien entendu de
la manière dont vous regardez les gens
va pas vous dire donc si vous les
considérez comme la grippe
si vous voulez donc la déduction en fait
c'est comme la grippe c'est pas vrai
c'était une autre maladie pour le savoir
il faut prendre le temps il faut les
regarder quand il faut commencer on les
examine ne regarde regarde ce qui se
passe on regarde les examens on lit
adil tes ratures de ceux qui en avaient
déjà eu 5000 cas comme ça nous est
arrivé dessus d'accord et à partir de ça
on définit une stratégie pas avant en
tout cas c'est ce que nous on a pensé
c'est ce que l'on a fait voilà
ultérieurement effectivement quand on a
vu cette situation nous on a décidé
qu'il fallait puisque nous ne savions
pas qui c'est qui allait avoir des
lésions et pas des lésions comme ça
avait été décrit en chine avant que ça
commence en france à eh bien on a décidé
qu'on a dit il faut tester les gens
quand ils viennent d'accord et on a
commencé à tester les gens quand ils
venaient quand on a tout de suite mis en
place notre système de pcr à très haut
débit parce que vous savez que les
français ont été rapatriés du yuan juste
à côté de chez nous donc très rapidement
on a commencé à tester des centaines de
des centaines de pcr et donc on a on a
fait ça voilà et donc au fur et à mesure
et bien on a augmenté 1
maintenant on a et on conseille aux gens
de mesurer leur saturation en oxygène
s'ils ont moins de 80 cas je pense qu'il
faut généraliser show qui viennent un
hôpital pour allant de l'oxygène parce
que sinon au moment où ils sentent
qu'ils sont à l'instant respiratoire
c'est juste avant de rentrer en réa et
même maintenant il ya même un marseille
il ya entre 50 et 60% des gens qui
rentrent en réanimation qui commencent
leurs soins en réanimation et cela on
aurait peut-être pu empêcher qu'ils
rentrent en réanimation les oxygen en
avant les anticoagulants avant voyez
donc c'est une notion qui est importante
qu'on pouvait pas connaître avant cette
discordance si vous voulez entre les
signes cliniques et l'état d'oxygénation
est d'ailleurs un de ceux qui est bon
pas mais plus jeunes 15 59 ans est mort
d'embolie pulmonaire
s'il était arrivé trois semaines plus
tard et c'est à mort parce qu'on savait
à ce moment là trois semaines plus tard
donc cette connaissance progressive si
vous voulez va mal avec des opinions
très tranchées initial et puis donc au
fur et à mesure du savoir nous avons
modifié les choses comme je voulais dire
on a fait on a proposé tout de suite
hein
une proposition des ces thérapeutiques
limitées ce qui avait été fait en chine
avec des posologies
quelle en est familier hydroxyque le
rookie et d'un essai thérapeutique qui a
toujours été avec un seul bras donc a
été validé par le cpp à l'époque on a
rajouté parce que c'est ça fait partie
de la pratique clinique de l'asie trop
micinn dont on savait par ailleurs que
c'était un antiviral sur des virus à arn
et on a eu la surprise de voir que les
charges virales diminué à une vitesse
absolument spectaculaire donc on a dit
mais voilà a prévenu mais tout de suite
on a toujours tenu au courant le
ministère et on a voulu faire un essai
thérapeutique en disant écoutez cette
azithromycine c'est tellement
impressionnant qu'on veut faire un
groupe hydroxyque eurokin un groupe
hydroxy chloroquine azithromycine et là
dans le cpp on est tombé sur la
méthodologie ce qu'ils voulaient qu'on
reparte à zéro et qu'on fasse un groupe
de placebo ce que moi je pouvais pas
faire parce que je considérais que
c'était pathétique quand j'aurai pas le
faire et donc qu'on a dit on va faire ce
que le soins courants et l'état de la
connaissance nous permet de dire ce
qu'on ait publié donc c'est ce qu'on a
fait et donc ensuite bien au fur et à
mesure on a continué à avoir une
politique de cette nature compte tenu du
fait que les gens ont soulevé quelque
chose qui m'étonne sur qui m'étonne
toujours d un sur le sur la toxicité
potentielle de l'hydroxyde brooklyn on a
rajouté pour pour être sûr qu'il y avait
aucun problème on a demandé au
professeur de cardiologie de vérifier
tous nos tous nos électrocardiogramme
on a fait systématiquement des cahiers
mis à tout le monde pour être sûr et on
a installé dans les chu la dosage du
potassium en moins d'une demi-heure pour
être sûr de pouvoir tout de suite dans
les traitements donc tout ça au fur et à
mesure que les questions sont levés on a
réagi pragmatiquement parce qu'on a
cette autonomie cette capacité à faire
les choses sur place et décider au fur à
mesure de les faire fonctionner et puis
voilà maintenant
soit les gens comme ça et puis je vous
ai donné tous ces chiffres sont
entièrement officiel aussi les chiffres
que je vous donne je peux pas inventer
chiche je donne tout ça tous les jours à
la rs tous les morts tous les détecter
tous les positifs on peut pas inventer
des chiffres dans ce pays c'est c'est
l'assistance publique enfin c'est pas
peut pas inventer les chiffres c'était
donc faut revenir sur terre gens qui
pensent qu'on invente les données mais
je sais pas ils savent tourner un pays
administrés parfois trop profond
je vous coupe parce que il y aura
beaucoup de questions catherine des
roches avait posé la question sur les
cpp et éthiques
oui moi je si vous voulez un avis j'ai
un avis qui est bien et donc que je veux
bien partager vous savez je me méfie
peut-être parce que le temps a passé je
me méfie beaucoup de toutes les modes
je suis pas très sensible non plus à ça
les modes méthodologique ce sont des
modes méthodologique c'est je vais vous
donner un exemple je voulais donner
parce que vous n'êtes pas obligés de me
croire mais je vous donne les documents
sur lequel on février ce document je lui
ai transmis c'est le cochrane library
ils sont spécialisés peut-être 25 ans
pour analyser toutes les publications et
toutes les recommandations d'accord et
comme maintenant les recommandations
depuis qu'il a été développé quelque
chose qui s'appelle la médecine basée
sur les évidences et de dire écoutez il
faut avoir un essai ou deux essais
randomisés donc là dessus ils ont étudié
et eux c'est les rois de cette analyse
là et eux ils ont analysé 250 méta
analyse des analyses qui regroupait
plusieurs années dans plus de 4000
analyse pour regarder s'il y avait une
différence de résultats et de qualité
entre les études randomisées les études
observationnelles et la conclusion c'est
qu'il n'ya pas de différence
d'accord donc le fait que les études
randomisées soit l'alpha et l'oméga de
la prise en charge thérapeutique
c'est juste parfait quand on
recommandations aussi parce qu'au bout
d'un mois ces choses qui pour moi aller
de soi mais s'il faut que j'explique jeu
les explique
bon j'ai regardé les recommandations de
la société américaine de maladies
infectieuses je vous ai donné la
référence avec quelqu'un qui a fait une
fois cette analyse en disant combien des
recommandations de la société américaine
de maladies infectieuses sont basés sur
au moins une étude randomisée à 18%
donc il ya 82 % des recommandations
thérapeutiques en maladies infectieuses
aux états unis pour lequel il y à 0 et
hull en devises est d'accord donc il
faut être un peu plus paisible avec sa
avant de dire vous savez c'est la règle
et comme ça sinon vous tuer c'est nous
qui savons c'est de l'idéologie c'est
une des raisons sur lesquelles je ne
veux pas discuter de ça ce plan
idéologique je les fais déjà j'avais
fait jeudi 10 h u qui est online où
j'avais invité costagliola pour parler
des méthodes nous n'étions pas d'accord
parce que sur le plan idéologique nous
ne sommes pas là maintenant nous ne
sommes pas d'accord non plus j'ai essayé
de l'exprimer comme médecin moi je ne
veux pas faire ça c'est un je ne peux
pas à dire un malade
écoutez je vais vous donner un truc je
sais pas si un traitement ou pas dedans
et je vais vous tire au sort je sais pas
le faire
je n'ai jamais su le faire et je ne le
ferai pas et les malades qui accepte je
vous assure que 1 soit ils n'ont pas
compris soit la plupart refusent parce
qu'on n'est pas là pour ça d'accord et
donc à une vraie question qui est est ce
que on devient maniaque du méthode si
vous voulez qui manifestement n'est pas
réellement pratiqué très fréquemment par
des praticiens d'accord ou est ce que on
est dans le contrat millénaire que nous
avons deux je vais faire du mieux que je
peux avec ce que je sais où ce que je
crois savoir à ce moment là pour vous
spécifiquement voilà et donc il ya une
vraie question et on a vu pour revenir
sur votre question précisément pour le
cpp une dérive qui s'est faite au début
les cpp c'était fait pour ça c'était
fait pour attendez vous n'allez pas
faire de l'expérience avec n'importe
quoi donc il faut qu'ils aient des
messages qui regarde donc mais prévu des
compositions de cp pêche parce qu'au
rappel ces anciens jeux parce que moi je
les ai vus naître le le dedans il était
prévu qu'ils aient des gens de sagesse
dedans donc il fallait qu'ils un prêtre
un pasteur un rabbin
des gens qui aient la sagesse et le
recul on dira écoutez faut faire
attention est ce que c'est nécessaire
moi je peux vous dire j'ai créé dans
cette dans ce pays le premier comité
d'éthique animal en france d'accord
c'est vrai qu'on avait des problèmes
terribles la faculté de médecine j'étais
en charge de la recherche
je vous parle de 1989 et on a fait un
comité d'éthique pour dire écoutez
est-ce que ce truc est vraiment
nécessaire est d'avoir les conditions de
vie des allemands est-ce que c'est pas
totalement inutile donc les cpp c'est à
ça que ça sert les cpp ça sert à aller
dans notre comité d'éthique animal on
avait interdit les essais sur les chiens
les chats et les sages ce qui
simplifiait les rapports avec la
population environnante
il y avait les rongeurs donc il y a une
vraie question c'est les cpp s'est pas
fait s'il ya une prise de pouvoir parler
méthodologistes c'est pas fait pour
valider la méthodologie c'est pour
savoir si ces mots rares c'est ça que ça
veut dire
est ce que on a le droit de faire ça
dans cette situation là et donc c'est
des lives la deux oui on a le droit de
faire ça dans cette situation là vous
avez le droit de faire de
l'expérimentation dans cette situation
là es tu devenu une dérive
administrativo méthodologique qui n'a
plus rien à voir avec la raison pour
laquelle ça a été créée donc c'est pour
ça que je pense qu'effectivement il faut
s'emparer
j'espère enfin moi je pense que le
législateur doit s'emparer de cette
question de cette réflexion sur
l'expérimentation humaine en sachant
écouter la l'histoire de nous faire
avoir un scpp pour d'autres pour faire
un écouvillon farrage et je pense que
c'est du délire voyez je pensais pas ça
mieux et je pense que deux en revanche
de faire des essais grande folie contre
les essais de non-infériorité et
sénonais infériorité c'est de dire aux
gens je passe donc si on peut faire
accepter de dirigeants on va tester un
médicament pour savoir s'il est aussi
bon que le traitement de référence qui
c'est qui peut faire ça qu'ils aient
quelques est la personne qui va accepter
une chose pareille ça il ya dizaine
d'essais de non-infériorité qui sont
faits tous les nouveaux médicaments ils
sont faits avec des essais de
non-infériorité parce qu'ils sont pas
meilleurs que les autres c'est pas vrai
on n'arrive pas à le démontrer donc si
vous voulez il ya une vraie réflexion de
fond avoir moral je pense qui est aussi
un des éléments probablement qui a fait
jaillir une telle une telle un tel
conflit c'était votre deuxième question
voilà je crois que vous avez répondu aux
questions catherine
oui si l'on tombe bien le parcours du
patient qui arrive chez vous est le même
depuis depuis le début au lieu
d'améliorer et quelles sont les voies
d'amélioration
si vous voulez où on a acheté du coup
quand on s'est rendu compte qu'on ne
voyait pas les saturations on a acheté
les des des appareils pour mesurer la
saturation à tous les gens qui se
présentaient d'accord donc maintenant à
partir de 95 ont fait les radios ont
fait c'est ça ça a changé le
l'anticoagulation systématique ça a
changé
voilà ce sont des choses qui ont changé
un an tout ça a changé au fur et mesure
bien merci
sylvie bernier merci monsieur le
président un professeur j'aurai deux
questions la première concerne la
démocratie
depuis le début de ces auditions on a
beaucoup parlé de démocratie sanitaire
en quelque sorte qu auraient été oubliés
on a oublié de d'entendre les familles
moi je trouve surtout oublier d'entendre
les patients je vais vous faire un petit
témoignage personnel qui est qui rejoint
celui de milliers de personnes j'ai été
malade vers le 15 mars à un moment où il
n'était pas possible d'être testé
puisque les tests étaient réservées aux
soignants et on nous ait disais donc de
rester chez nous avec des boîte de
doliprane et à ce moment là les malades
de n'étaient en fait que des chiffres
on recevait tous les jours le nombre de
morts le nombre de malades et on n'était
guère plus que ça et je veux dire qu'au
moment où vous avez lancé votre retrait
c'est vous a été le premier à nous
donner de l'espoir
je vous en sais gré je tiens à le dire
ici jusqu'à vos travaux le seul espoir
qu'on avait c'était une boîte de
doliprane voilà alors en matière de
démocratie sanitaire ça c'est une chose
mais pour le coup aujourd'hui on a le
sentiment qu'il n'ya pas de démocratie
dans le monde de la recherche
alors pourquoi est-ce que
c'est la force de la pandémie qui
explique ça est ce que c'est la pression
médiatique ou est ce que c'est le fait
comme vous l'avez dit en préambule le
fait qu'il n'y a pas de patron qu'il
n'est pas de leader dans le monde des
maladies infectieuses
ma deuxième question portera sur le
virus vous avez déclaré récemment il
existe deux hypothèses particulièrement
plausible soit que l'épidémie
disparaisse complètement
soit que l'épidémie reprennent et
deviennent saisonnière comment ça peut
être un cas où l'autre merci je suis je
jouerai si je suis très sensible à ce
que vous dites je vais vous dire la
raison pour laquelle en pratiquant en
réalité où ça y est souvent c'est des
anecdotes ou des moments de vie qui
déclenche de tourner les choses je pense
que je les dis à 100 mais il se trouve
qu'une fois passant un dimanche pour
voir comment les choses se passaient au
moment où elles grandissent et j'avais
une de nos assistantes qui est une fille
merveilleuse qui avait passé le week end
à qui était épuisée et elle était en
train de se disputer avec un papa qui
avait un gosse de trois mois dans les
bras qui avait un masque sur lui sur le
gosse et elle voulait pas le tester
parce que ça faisait pas partie des
critères qu'on s'était daudet et donc ce
type disait d'écouté moi je suis passé
par un aéroport amsterdam j'ai peur que
mon gosse aux ballades et je suis dit
'ça suffit que vous faites des coûts
vision grosse ayant partir à
tranquilliser les terrifier ça ne
changeait pas les choses on peut pas
c'est tellement de vies ils étaient
négatifs
on a appris après qu'à cet âge là
c'était la plupart du temps négatif mais
on peut pas laisser les gens sans leur
proposer ou leur donner mon avis et je
pense que d'être sur le terrain
voyez c'est la raison pour laquelle je
crois tellement honorée d'être sur le
terrain ça nous a fait changer notre
manière de percevoir les choses parce
que on s'est rendu compte qu'il fallait
faire quelque chose non seulement
effectivement les détecter d'abord pour
les rassurer pour leur dire s'il était
ou n'était pas positif
d'autre part pour les prendre en charge
donc sur le sur la question de
l'évolution
je ne sais pas je pondère toujours ce
que je dis en disant je le vois je crois
pas au modèle jeu propre à la prédiction
tout
ce par quoi moi j'arrive à raisonner ces
par analogie d'accord donc je dis
écouter ce qui a plus proche passe comme
ça peut-être que ça va se passer comme
ça c'est la seule chose que je peux dire
donc vous savez qu'il ya s'il y avait
six coronavirus avant en a quatre qui
sont saisonniers ils ont bien dû
commencer par être autre chose que
saisonniers comme la grippe je voulais à
la première grille au moins du xxème
siècle n'a pas du tout été saisonnière
doit être l'année a commencé l'été c'est
la grippe espagnole soul et puis c'est
devenu quelque chose qui est rythmée et
qui est plutôt par quand il ya un
nouveau variant qui est plutôt
effectivement saisonniers pour des
raisons qu'on comprend qu'ils n'ont pas
c'est pas le froid puisqu'il y en a dans
le sud en afrique
pendant des années les gens pensaient
qu'ils avaient pas donné par l'afrique
parce qu'il pensait que douce et
influenza
ça veut dire de m fredo influence du
froid donc ça a été décrit voulait à la
renaissance comme étant une maladie qui
étaient sous influence du froid bien sûr
c'était nous qui le décrivent hier en
europe
et comme chez nous ces saisonniers au
moment où le froid arrive on pensait que
c'est une maladie liée au froid mais il
y en a autant dans les pays chauds même
plus et la zone un portable il y en a
toute l'année et un peu plus pour
l'afrique que je connais un peu
l'afrique de l'ouest dans la plus
pendant la saison des pluies au
contraire donc on connaît on comprend
pas bien ses rythmes saisonniers mais
chez nous c'est vrai qu'il ya une
saisonnalité
tous les virus respiratoires non pas la
même saisonnalité je vous parlais par
influence des trois c'est le printemps
et l'automne
c'est pas l'hiver alors donc si par
analogie fort c'est à dire écoutez
comment à quoi ça va ressembler
analogiquement le sar ce premier hop ça
il ya une pique et presse est arrêté en
juillet donc il ya plus de cas du tout
et on a plus depuis
d'accord les autres coronavirus qui
s'est passé c'est que il ya un moment
probablement n'a pas su quand parce
qu'on les a découvert un peu par hasard
les autres coronavirus endémique et bien
il ya probablement une diffusion qui
s'est fait un peu partout dans le monde
parce que lui est partout partout on
trouve en afrique on trouve partout en
chine et donc il s'est installé
maintenant durablement avec nous et il a
une d'épidémie mais au jeu
saisonnière avec quelques cas
sporadiques pendant le reste de l'année
et donc c'est les deux modèles que je
connais des eaux coronavirus demandé
écoutez voilà dans les modèles que je
connais c'est cela donc les chances que
ça ressemble au modèle qu'on connaît
déjà mais peut-être que ce sera quelque
chose de totalement différent parce que
c'est une autre maladie est une nouvelle
maladie et là en plus il est en train de
se passer des choses que moi j'avais pas
vu décrite en tout cas avec les
coronavirus et la vitesse de mutation
qu'il a actuellement et donc je ne sais
pas ce qu'il va devenir
vous n'avez pas répondu à ma première
question sur la démocratie dans le monde
la recherche qui à mon sens écoutez je
je je redoute que la recherche auprès du
tout démocratique
c'est je pense que là la recherche des
clubs le sport de haut niveau
ouais c'est pas démocratique l'idée que
c'est démocratique si vous voulez alors
dans les phases stationnaire c'est un
des grands grands épistémologique
historien des sciences dit vous savez il
ya trois phases dans un domaine de de la
recherche dans un domaine particulier
il ya une première phase qui est une
phase pionnière est dans la phase
pionnière sont des gens qui sont
audacieux qui brise les lignes qui sont
poison n'est toute leur vie d'accord
c'est les pionniers et puis ensuite il
ya une phase de plateau si vous voulez
dans lequel qu'il est dite normale dans
lequel les choses avancent petit à petit
on rajoute un petit peu un petit peu un
petit peu c'est une phase dans lequel
qui devient collective c'est ce qu'on
appellerait la recherche démocratique
dans lequel les études multicentriques
avec sept pays européens chacun rajoute
un petit bout ça c'est la face du
plateau et puis malheureusement après il
ya la face du déclin c'est à dire que le
chant s'épuiser puis un autre champ qui
les kinés c'est comme ça et c'est tout
les épistémologie ce temps observé ça il
ya des phases
et quand vous êtes à une nouvelle phase
en particulier dans les phase de
découverte
le conflit sont terrifiants parce que et
c'est toute l'histoire comme ça si vous
lisez enfin moi je vous recommande de
lire les changer d'avis un livre
merveilleux de la tour qui s'appelle
guerre et paix des microbes
la fille de pasteur c'est génial voilà
mais c'est vrai en oeuvre scientifique
c'est pas un roman
lis tous les journaux de l'époque tous
tous tous s'y rapporte ça pour voir
comment pasteur a réussi avec des en
ayant des forces qui était à la fois des
forces politiques des alliés qui étaient
les hygiénistes comment s'est passée
l'idée germe
ça a été un combat terrible vous savez
que la marque qui était dans notre
inventeur à nous de l'évolution a été
condamné a le plus parlé par un team qui
était un immense scientifique qui était
cuvier qui était à l'époque tout
puissant science et qu'il a réellement
rendu muet alors que c'était plus grands
scientifiques de l'évolution du monde
c'est c'est la vie c'est un sport de
combat
je m'excuse mon prochain livre s'appelle
la sosta sport de combat
merci vous avez par les professeurs
avant de donner la parole s'il le veut
bien bernard jaume i ii de vitesse de
mutation
ce matin on nous a dit qu'il semblait
que le virus ne mute et pas je sais pas
qui a quoi moi je sais ce que j'ai moi
donc je pense qu'on fait plus de
séquences que n'importe qui ont fait
énormément de séquencer dans des
conditions j'ai obligé de faire venir
les gens le week-end pour pouvoir
continuer à faire les séquences donc on
a fait à peu près 500 séquence de virus
depuis juillet parce qu on était étonnés
de voir la forme que prenaient les cas
cliniques et l'épidémie depuis juillet
le paraissait différentes donc on avait
et dès le départ on a trouvé un mutant
qu'on a appelée marseille qui est assez
online vous pouvez les regarder qui est
assez qui présentait plus de mutations
que ce qu'on avait l'habitude de voir et
23 habitations par rapport aux à la
souche de human donc on pensait qu
réellement et celui là on a retracé sa
source
c'est à dire on y est venu du maghreb
sur les bateaux et tous les premiers cas
ont été vraiment lié à ça et ensuite une
diffusion qui s'est passé
d'environnement on a eu 100 cas de ce
virus là actuellement ce virus-là à peu
près disparu depuis août et on pensait
que c'est lui qui avait plus le truc et
on a maintenant 7 mi temps
celui qui est le plus
celui qui est le plus actif actuellement
c'est ce qu'on a appelé quatre una 60
cartes du 4 et globalement si vous
voulez si vous regardez le nom mais vous
voyez bien qu'on peut pas parler de la
même chose
moi je vous assure c'est des données je
viens de les écrire c'est de calais a
gardé son online parce que mon mais
effectivement c'est une deux au
traitement mais tout online mana en
particulier dans des situations un pique
nique pour que tout le monde puisse en
profiter
si on regarde nous tous les virus que
nous avons eu jusqu'en mai et qu'on
regarde l'heure si vous regardez sur
notre site vous le verrez on a beaucoup
réfléchi pour leur présenter de manière
qui est visible sur un cercle
le degré de variation par rapport à la
souche initial si vous regardez la
différence entre les différentes souches
que nous avions par rapport à la souche
initial elle donnait un cercle diamètre
x
si vous regardez maintenant ce que nous
avons depuis juillet ce ce diamètre a
été multiplié par dix c'est à dire la
variabilité des virus que nous avons
maintenant les virus que nous avons
maintenant son antre présente entre eux
dix fois plus de variations que les
virus que nous avions jusqu'en mai
d'accord et c'est des variations qui
sont très intéressantes parce que ce
sont des variations convoi dans la
dégradation des génomes en général c'est
à dire c'est d'aider des variations ces
quatre bases dans les génétique
qui sont hâtés gc l'adn et pour les
virus à arn place d'un thé vous avez eu
et donc la dégradation de ces verrues
est une normalement et réparer parce que
la plupart du temps est délétère et donc
là ce convoi majoritairement c'est des
mutations de tv rue qui traduisent soit
l'effet d'une enzyme qui est bien connu
chez les humains qui s'appelle la peau
beck qui a l'habitude de couper les
russes donc peut-être qu'au fur et à
mesure que ce virus s'est répandu et est
arrivée des formes qui qui est qui qui
permettent la transformation de ces
verrues soit il est donc soit il se
passe quelque chose dans les rues ce qui
permet ça mais ce que je peux vous dire
leur sens là aussi étudié peut-être que
delfraissy n'a pas vu encore mais moi je
n'ai vu parce qu'on a envoyé le papier
on a comparé 100 cas à partir de juillet
et sans qu'avant pour regarder quel
était le degré de leurs troubles de
coagulation et donc ils ont beaucoup
moins de troubles de coagulation ils
sont moins sévères et la mortalité est
plus faible
donc il se passe quelque chose avec ce
lyrisme qui en fait quelque chose de
différent voilà et donc moi je regrette
voyez que quand on vous dit ça mais moi
j'ai téléphoné au conseiller du ministre
pour lui dire et pour lui donnez donnez
donc la question que vous me posiez à
toutes les semaines je téléphone en
octobre dernier qui est le conseiller du
ministre pour lui dire écoute je vais
parler de ça voilà ce que nous avons si
vous voulez les données vous les avez
jeu je reste à l'intérieur d'une
démocratie où je partage mes résultats
mais je les partage ensuite avec la
planète entière sanka permettez moi
d'insister parce que la sphère me semble
d'importance sans qu'à comparer prêt
avant et après le mois de mai c'est
suffisant pour je sais pas ce que vous
appelez suffisant global moi non plus
moi non plus avec global board mais est
ce suffisant pour affirmer oui à
mutation ah non mais il avoue ses
constantes et la mutation c'est rien
n'avancera l'habitation c'est un truc
qu'on constate dans le virus dont on a
fait 550 de génomes viraux d'accord donc
là de juillet août
c'est visible on voit à la place d'avoir
cette base et 7 bat toi
on s'est rendu compte nouer d'autres que
l'on pouvait séquence est directement
les virus avec les nouvelles on peut
peut séquencer les virus maintenant
directement en dehors de sans avoir
besoin de les cultiver
quand est ce que tu es beaucoup mais
pratiquement chez tous ceux qui ont
moins de 20 ct on peut avoir le virus
entier dans les huit heures qui suivent
le génome entier à 8 heures qui suivent
donc je voulais de pratiquer des génomes
quand on a tous encore une fois c'est à
dire on a le prélèvement on voit que les
cités sont bas on peut les envoyer
on peut les envoyer en séquences et puis
on a nous un mécanisme d' analyse des
séquences qui nous permet de voir ça
voilà bien le papier sur notre site vous
pouvez seulement nous regardons tout
cela bien sûr avec beaucoup d'intérêt
bernard jomier merci monsieur le
président je voudrais monsieur quillan
revenir sur votre propos liminaires et
parce que le professeur à outils a
répondu et je voudrais lui expliquer
quel était l'intérêt de notre démarche
qui a été de vouloir vous auditionnés en
présence et on débat avec d'autres
spécialistes d'autres personnalités
ayant une compétence éminentes comme la
vôtre
c'est une méthode que nous utilisons
couramment dans cette commission enquête
pourquoi parce que et la discussion qui
vient d'avoir lieu le démontre
parfaitement vous pouvez avec un savoir
technique qui est incomparable aux
nôtres en la matière nous faire un
exposé pendant 10 minutes de virologie
pour nous expliquer que le virus semble
muté mais un autre virologue et milan le
professeur lina nous a expliqué et nous
a dit plusieurs fois que non le virus
n'avait pas muté et ça ça ne fait pas
beaucoup avancer notre compréhension
nous nous nous avons besoin nous ne
sommes pas dans des conflits
ce n'est pas notre méthode ici de mettre
en scène des matchs de catch et de
générer du conflit
c'est notre méthode de faire ressortir
les points qui font clivages et si pour
vous ça peut être pénible
ce que vous avez des conflits avec
d'autres collègues d'autres confrères
qui sont parfois effectivement virulent
nous ce n'est pas ce que nous ce n'est
pas notre jaillir ce n'est pas notre
problème j'en suis tout à fait désolé
pour les uns et les autres mais nous
nous devons rendre compte aux français
aux personnes qui résident sur notre
territoire de ce qui s'est passé et sur
ces sujets fondamentaux qui sont les
vôtres la recherche les tests de
dépistage vous faites partie des
personnes qui avaient une expertise et
qui ont été en désaccord avec d'autres
et pouvoir vous entendre vous répondre
entre vous et pour nous essentiel dans
la construction de notre représentation
et notre compréhension de ce qui se
passe de ce qui s'est passé de ce qui se
passe voilà donc je vais pas poursuivre
là dessus mais comprenez juste que nous
ne souhaitions pas vous faire vivre un
moment pénible pour vous à titre
personnel je comprendre que ce n'est pas
agréable d'être poursuivi devant des
instances disciplinaires d'avoir des
procédures en justice mais nous nous
avons la nécessité de mener notre
travail dans les meilleures conditions
et très tranquillement professeurs avec
le respect que je vous dois vous ne nous
aidez pas là dans notre tâche votre
exposé est certes très intéressant mais
ne nous ils ne mettent pas à progresser
de façon suffisante alors je veux en
venir à quelques à quelques quelques
questions ah non vous allez répondre
at-elle il en faites pas vous avez
région venir à quelques questionnements
parce que vous avez eue là la tension je
dirais de nous envoyer en préliminaire à
cette audition un document extrêmement
complet de réponse à notre question ce
matin nous débattions et nous l'avions
fait au rapporteur pardon aux
rapporteurs
mais vous ne vous inquiétez pas cher que
les vous allez tout comprendre ce matin
nous avons eu une discussion et les
jours lors de deux sont présentes sur la
question des tests et de la lenteur
refait pas l'histoire du déploiement des
thèses dans notre pays et au printemps
quand nous étions en pleine vague
épidémique
nous voyons tous devant votre institut
des fils de personnes qui venaient pour
faire des têtes et vous pratiquiez
beaucoup de tests et dont le
document vous nous avez envoyé vous
dites j'ai fait deux cent mille nous
avons fait la chute deux cent mille
tests sur cent mille personnes alors est
ce que vous pourriez nous préciser ce
calendrier tant que globalement les
patients qui ont été hospitalisés en
maladies infectieuses en ile de france
n'ont pas eu de perte de chance par
rapport à ceux qui ont été hospitalisés
en maladies infectieuses dans d'autres
régions donc qu'est-ce que cette
destruction physique dont vous avez
parlé j'ai compris que le fait d'avoir
scindé géographiquement mais j'imagine
des services des capacités mais
j'imagine que ça allait au delà puisque
la critique est très dur et puis enfin
dernier point que je ne souhaitais pas
soulevé parce que c'est pas l'obliger
exactement ici mais vous êtes vous êtes
revenu sur diderot xi chloroquine et
l'azithromycine et vous avez dans votre
exposé préliminaire expliqué un principe
qui me paraît très sain celui du
benchmark vous regardez ce qu'il fallait
et rangez vous avez cité la chine et
l'important savoir quel qui là qu'elle a
accumulées aujourd'hui il semblerait que
la plupart des pays de des états unis au
japon la corée du sud à l'allemagne en
passant par la chine ne recommande pas
ce traitement là donc il semblerait que
la science a parlé et c'est la liste des
pays qui ont qu'ils ne recommandent pas
ou qui même déconseillent l'utilisation
l'hydroxyde chloroquine et du peu de
distribuer à tout le monde la deuxième
chose c'est que le temps encore une fois
fait le tri au début les gens disaient
ça ne sert à rien de faire des tests
pourquoi ils n'ont pas fait des tests
par simple parce que les centres
nationaux de référence lors on dit
écoutez c'est compliqué difficile de
faire les tests et une fois que cet
embranchement était parti est
extrêmement difficile de revenir sur cet
embranchement extrêmement difficile et
donc c'est pas vrai qu'il n'est pas les
réactifs je les dis je le redis puis je
vous le redis encore une fois si vous
voulez les laboratoires vétérinaires ont
écrit à peu près à tout le monde y
compris au conseil scientifique pour
leur dire qu'ils avaient à faire quoi
300 mille tests et les autres n'auront
pas répondu nous on a répondu et on sent
des services d'accor donc vous ne pouvez
pas penser que dans une crise comme ça
où il ya des opinions diffèrent
vous avez les par la magie du sénat
faire que les gens votent d'accord la
fin c'est le temps qui trient le temps
tri et le à la fin on voit ce qui s'est
passé d'accord c'est à la fin ce qui
s'est passé quand encore une fois à la
ligue roc cyclo qui n'est donc pour les
tests on a fait ce qu'on fait quand on
est en situation de crise c'est à dire
tous les jours on s'est débrouillé nous
mêmes on a fabriqué de quoi faire 430
mille tests nous mêmes
chez nous l'eau phillies est d'accord on
s'est organisé pour faire face ces
l'intendance qui a suivi la décision
c'est pas la tendance qui a commandé la
décision c'est comme ça qu'on a vu les
choses et c'est comme ça que je
continuerai à les voir quant à votre
opinion sur qui et kind en taille rossi
chloroquine je vous assure je viens
d'avoir un papier accepté sur lequel on
a mis l'ensemble des pays qui
recommandait le cycle en chine
la mortalité dans l'ensemble des pays
qui regardent avec login et ça n'est pas
ce que vous dites donc je ne suis pas là
donc vous évitez vous émettez une
opinion scientifique et donc vous voyez
je ne suis pas de corps et donc que
chacun fasse son métier et vachon de
regarder vous entendrez deux éco et le
temps triera à la fin on verra bien si
vous nous bien sûr que tu arrêtes c'est
donc c'est je sais pas encore dans le
document je crois c'est dans l'obs et
dans le document
c'est dans le document que nous
communiquerons bien sûr l'ensemble de
nos conseillers parce que la lecture et
il est intéressant de nos commissaires
pardon monsieur le président je ne suis
pas dans un débat d'opinion je suis
rapporteur d'une co je suis rapporteur
d'une commission denquête et professeurs
je vais vous citer une liste incomplète
d'ailleurs des pays qu actuellement dans
les autorités de santé des conseils d'
usage de l'hydroxyde chloroquine si ce
que disent ces autorités est inexact je
veux bien l'entendre que veut bien
entendre votre opinion qui ne la partage
pas mais vous ne pouvez pas dire que
c'est une opinion de ma part aux usa là
ni h et lignes fixes diseases society of
america déconseille d'utiliser son lot
de roxy chloroquine en grande bretagne
c'est déconseillé dans le monde
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
de demande de ne pas l'utiliser quelle
que soit la gravité l'italie déconseille
la belgique déconseille l'allemagne
déconseille le brésil le portugal la
chine le chinese center for disease
control and prevention estime que
l'utilisation doit être déconseillé
quelle que soit la gravité le japon
l'australie l'espagne le canada
l'european medicines agency pour
l'europe la suisse et la corée du sud
je n'aimais pas une opinion si ces
recommandations sont erronées je peux
l'entendre et jeu j'attends qu'on nous
l'expliquent mais je ne vais pas mené de
débats scientifiques avec vous ce n'est
pas le sujet je réfute simplement
professeur le fait que vous transformiez
ma question en un débat d'opinion entre
vous et moi je respecte votre opinion et
je vous aimez les recommandations des
pays concernés encore une fois je vous
recommande de vous verrez encore une
fois on a un papier dans lequel on
explique ça est extrêmement précisément
sondés général vous savez pour faire des
généralités trouvé qu'on est d'accord
c'est extrêmement simple moi je peux
vous dire aux états unis et agissent un
pays fédéral il ya un tiers des états
dans lequel reed roxy floraux qui n'est
recommandée il ya un tiers des états
dans lequel il sert pas trop ce qu'il
faut faire et un tiers des états qui
suivent les recommandations de fossiles
c'est un pays fédéral
donc il n'ya pas d'homogénéité aux états
unis et compare même aux états unis à
des conflits les conflits autour de
l'hydroxyde de routine sont mondiaux il
compare même aux états unis état par
état
quelle est la mortalité et yoko vide par
rapport à la prescription ou non
d'hydroxyde lockheed
pardon la liste oui oui vous les
regarderai la liste nous on a fait une
liste on a marqué chaque source
à chaque de chaque source d'où elle
vient comment est fait comme on fait de
la séance donc vous vous le lirez vous
avez si vous souhaitez que je vous
envoie le pré print je vous enverrai n'y
a pas de problème mais moi je le fais il
se trouve que c'est un sujet sur lequel
vous imaginez bien qu'on travaille nous
on a estimé qu'il ya 4,4 à 10,6
milliards de gens qui vivaient dans les
pays dans lequel ont recommandé ou entre
où on dit vous pouvez étiez l'année
d'auxi chloroquine se voulait donc
encore une fois donc ça veut dire que
ces débats qui sont des débats
scientifiques très bien nous on l'a
écrit il ya une liste une liste des
sources comme on a l'habitude de faire
et puis et puis voilà regarderai si vous
arrivez à les analyser
où vous les ferez analysés par quelqu'un
qui vous aidera à les analyser mais on
ne peut pas de manière péremptoire dire
écoutez tous ces pays là ne le font pas
elles ne l'ont pas fait c'est parce que
c'est pas mal
fané palais de l'elysée merci il y avait
la question sur les tests donc vous
dites vous êtes s'est constitué vous
même vous avez fait vous même vos tests
pour arriver à cenon et puis vous les
avez eu au niveau des laboratoires
vétérinaires et ça ça n'a pas été ça n'a
pas été très rapidement pris en compte
sur le plan national quoi un retard par
rapport à écouter mozart ou non j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire au président qui m'a
confirmé quand j'ai revu que la pcr est
une chose extrêmement simple qui posait
pas beaucoup de problèmes et que tout le
monde était capable de faire comme on
voit maintenant et à l'époque il a été
surpris et quand il est revenu il m'a
dit écoutez c'est vrai vous avez été
premier à me dire ça on me disait que
c'est un truc très compliquée qui
pourrait être fait dans les centres de
référence donc il est parti 1 c'est ce
qu'on nous a régulièrement libre donc si
vous voulez là encore je ne crois pas
que quand on soit dans une situation
comme ça parce que je me suis déjà
trouvé
si vous voulez on puisse avoir un débat
entre les gens qui disent et c'est la
chose la plus simple du monde parce que
nous on en faisait déjà derrière 150000
de pc et que l'adn c'est l'adn
si vous voulez et puis les gens qui
disent non c'est très compliqué et c'est
très complexe c'est le temps qui trie
et c'est pas ici et maintenant qu'on va
trier tous les éléments qui sont liées à
cette donnée pour l'autre question que
vous posez non il faut regarder les
morts vous les regarderai les morts moi
je les connais les morts je sais qui est
mort dans quelle ville dans quelles
régions et communes mort et combien une
jeune qui sont bons je le sais bien
donc je connais les résultats là aussi
il faut aller regarder les résultats et
regarder les otages osé publier
d'ailleurs les résultats et c'est ceux
de santé publique france n'est pas les
miens il faut regarder bien il ya une
morale il ya une surmortalité ici et
dans l'est qui est tout à fait
spécifique qui a quelque chose de
particulier avec une vraie sous
mortalité et y compris dans des tranches
d'âge on n'a pas l'habitude de voir une
surmortalité donc si vous voulez
d'ailleurs si en pratique de ne pas
traiter pas des moustiques et les gens
c'était la même chose que quand on les
traite et des mercis conso est plus dans
merci les questions des rapporteurs
étant terminée j'invite maintenant nous
commissaire a posé les questions et j'ai
déjà 3 3 6 6 3 9 11 inscriptions donc je
vais les prendre quelques uns par
quelques-uns et vous répondrais de façon
collective en notant après de façon
groupée
merci davance martin livriez merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
professeur rappelle je vous rappelle
simplement que nous excuse moi tu avoir
trouvé martin que nous devons finir nos
travaux pour 17 17
voilà il est 16 heures 13 très bien que
quelques questions j'espère rapide
la première que je reprends le début de
cette pandémie on est dans une pandémie
arrive assez rapidement une controverse
scientifique qui prend toute la place au
niveau communication et presse et de
cette controverse on arrive même à un
combat scientifique
je ne suis ni médecin ni spécialiste et
je suis avalé par ce combat par cette
inquiétude qui naît entre nous tous
parce qu'on ne comprend pas tout et ça
fait quatre points que ce combat dur
perdure et continue et je me dis
qu'aujourd'hui il ya peut-être une
possibilité de s'en sortir mais là c'est
vous qui pouvez vraiment mai
vous avez déjà donné un élément de
réponse tollé en disant idéologiquement
je ne peux pas et pourtant je me pose la
question
ce combat qui ne méritent pas je trouve
d'être pourrait s'arrêter si vous
décidiez vous parce que vous en avez la
capacité les moyens et aujourd'hui
malheureusement visiblement le les
patients puisqu'il ya de plus en plus de
patients et de malades dans votre
département de faire justement ces
essais en double aveugle parce que
finalement on se dit je comprends votre
principe de dire pas de placebo pour les
parce que parce qu'il ya des gens qui
n'ont pas être soigné mais aujourd'hui
si vous avez raison si vous aviez raison
depuis le début
combien de patients n'ont pas été
soignées parce que finalement on a
préféré l'idéologie à une tentative dont
je vous pose vraiment cette question
parce qu'elle me paraît tellement
importante aujourd'hui de se dire si
vous avez raison professeurs c'est
tellement important aujourd'hui si vous
avez raison et ce que l'idéologie est
supérieur à le fait d'avoir raison donc
voilà ma première question
la deuxième concerne indirectement cela
aussi c'est la communication est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la communication n'a pas
pris le pas sur le vrai travail
scientifique et sur ce besoin de
controverses qui est indispensable je
pense dans le monde scientifique mais
comme partout ailleurs et qu'aujourd'hui
on est plus dans la controverse menant
le combat et comment on sort de ce débat
pour avancer pour permettre au monde
entier s'en sortir parce que c'est un
sujet mondial c'est pas un sujet franco
français et bah écoutez vous ce sera
tout pour le moment parce que j'avais eu
votre question je les ai perdus merci
président bonjour bonsoir je suis
sénateur des français établis hors de
france
vous bénéficiez d'une grande renommée
une reconnaissance parmi les trois
millions et demi de français qui vivent
à l'étranger
je voulais vous poser une question cette
pandémie a débuté en asie à toucher à
peu près simultanément l'europe et
l'amérique du nord puis l'amérique
latine au mois d'avril du quai d'orsay
en passant par de nombreux experts des
projections catastrophique était annoncé
sur l'afrique
certains pays on avait même le nombre de
respirateurs je pense entre autres à
l'ethiopie par habib par centaines ou
par million d'habitants on avait le mali
on avait l'egypte et un certain nombre
de pays qui finalement n'ont pas connu
ces vagues aussi importante que dans
d'autres territoires
vous-même français d'étrangers vous vous
connaissez très bien l'afrique et le
sénégal en particulier et j'aimerais
savoir pourquoi et comment vous
expliquez que cette catastrophe annoncée
n'a pas eu lieu et quel est votre
diagnostic et enfin une dernière
question très rapide avec plus de dix
mille cas en 24 heures ces derniers
temps on peut comprendre l'anxiété de la
société face à cette pandémie
si vous aviez trois recommandations à
faire
quelle serait-elle trois recommandations
quelle serait-elle et comment voyez vous
l'évolution de cette pandémie dans les
deux mois qui viennent puisque c'est là
qu'on nous annonce aussi selon les
sources des avis très divergents
merci merci roger karoutchi du
professeur moi je partage la dernière
question d'ailleurs de mon ami régnard
c'est vrai qu'on aimerait tous avoir un
peu votre opinion sur ce qui va se
passer au ce qui pourrait se passer dans
les semaines qui viennent moi je
voudrais poser deux questions assez
clair 1
qu'est ce que vous pensez du fait que
les médecins libéraux que les médecins
tout court
beaucoup ont été bien souvent contraints
de ne pas appliquer votre traitement et
de ne pas pouvoir le prescrire à un
moment où dans le même temps les mêmes
autorités scientifiques affirmaient
qu'il n'y avait pas de traitement qu'il
n'y avait pas de médicaments et que dans
ses conséquences dans ces conditions les
gens comme disait ma collègue sylvie
vermeillet soit on leur disait vous
prendrez le doliprane
soit ils pouvaient avoir votre
traitement et si ça n'était pas ça il
n'y avait en tout cas au début rien est
ce que c'est normal dans en 2020 dans un
pays comme le nôtre de dire à des gens à
qui on dit vous êtes positif
vous restez chez vous priez et prenez
duo libre est ce que c'est normal
ma deuxième question chacun dit ce qu'il
veut ma deuxième question elle et elle
est simple ce matin je disais au
professeur delfraissy
j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour le conseil
scientifique pour chacun de ses membres
on sait pas le sujet mais la réalité
elle est quand même que l'autorité du
conseil scientifique ne semble pas
toujours être suivie par le gouvernement
ce qui veut dire que on a
institutionnalisé un débat sur mon
passionnant entre scientifiques médecins
dans les médias et ailleurs mais qui en
réalité extrêmement anxiogènes pour la
population est ce que dans ces
conditions là vous pensez que le conseil
scientifique tel que défini avec les
missions qui sont les siennes a encore
du sens aujourd'hui
olivier henno oui merci professeur pour
vos propos - j'ai une question qui est
en prolongement avec le débat de ce
matin ce matin on nous a dit
le système de santé français n'était pas
prêt alors on a eu quelques explications
un peu complexe un peu flou parmi
lesquels oui mais un autre système de
santé il est trop curatif alors ma
question elle concerne votre que
diagnostic par rapport à notre système
de santé
pourquoi nous n'étions pas prêts moi je
pense que ça n'est pas seulement une
question de moyens puisque notre pays
consacre un certain nombre de moyens à
son système de de santé je pense que
c'est plus une question d'organisation
et d'ailleurs on nous a dit aussi que
parmi les pays qui étaient mieux
préparés il y avait l'allemagne et puis
je m'interroge aussi sur le fait que
notre système
[Musique]
comme beaucoup de choses en france
d'ailleurs et souvent un peu trop
corporatistes et donc je voulais votre
diagnostic sur eux sur toutes ces
questions je vous remercie
merci lapin oui professeur président
merci de questions très rapide parce que
vous y avez répondu en partie déjà
néanmoins je voudrais quelques
précisions sur la première elle concerne
la relation à la chine
ce matin le professeur delfraissy au nom
du conseil scientifique nous disait que
les informations qu'il avait lui-même en
échange direct avec les chinois sous
l'oeil bienveillant de l' oms nous
faisait comprendre dans ses propos qu'il
n'avait qu'une confiance très très
réservé sur ce que les chinois nous
apportait aussi bien en termes
scientifiques cliniques et qu'il doutait
fort de beaucoup de leurs propos quant à
vous effectivement vous êtes appuyé au
départ quand vous avez lancé le
processus chloroquine en disant voilà
c'est peut-être la solution est
aujourd'hui moi je n'ai pas un regard
assez pertinent ni même assez globale
pour juger de l'efficacité ou non mais
en tout cas vous êtes appuyé sur les
expertises chinoise pour dire voilà en
chine il ya quelque chose qui marche et
bien testons le en france donc je
voudrais savoir quelle est en fait cette
relation et cette différence entre
les apports du conseil scientifique et
puis ce que vous vous avez décrété puis
deuxièmement je voudrais qu'on revienne
sur la mutation
la mutation et les souches vous nous
dites
effectivement il ya de plus en plus de
souche en tout cas c'est ce que vous
constatez c'est ce que j'ai cru
comprendre dans votre exposé mais ce qui
fait les choux les souches
c'est les mutations du virus des
différentes souches de virus qu'on
rencontre elles proviennent de la
mutation du virus
qu'elles soient ou non plus pathogène
plus virulente mais en tout cas elles
viennent de là donc ce qu'on voudrait
savoir simplement parce que tous les
gens qui nous écoutent c'est ce qu'ils
entendent à la radio ou à la télé le
virus mute il oui ou non parce que ce
matin on nous a dit non
oui merci beaucoup aussi le président
monsieur le professeur
j'ai une première question concernant
les essais thérapeutiques à vous avez
des protocoles
alors est-ce que des à votre
connaissance vous avez évoqué la
bibliographie que vous avez faite
concernant les chinois mais est ce que
dans ce que vous préconisiez il ya eu
des études comparatives qu'ils soient
faites en fonction de vos préconisations
parce que bon il ya des personnes qui
ont dit que c'était pas forcément
pertinent donc est-ce que vous avez
connaissance de l'équipe qui aurait
utilisé conformément à vos
recommandations
vos protocole la deuxième chose la
liberté de la liberté de prescrire a été
mise en cause dans notre pays alors
pensez vous qu'il ya eu des pertes de
change liées à cette liberté à cette
obstruction
la dernière chose revient alors ça
concerne également les mutations
alors je voudrais savoir vous avez dit
qu'il y avait vous avez commandé des
génomes que vous avez fait des cinq ans
agit a eu
vous avez eu cette mutation alors sur
quoi portait ces mutations s des
mutations ou les permutations d'acides
aminés à quel niveau il y avait ces
mutations pour que ce sera un peu plus
clair pour tout le monde
je vous remercie mr si vous allez
répondre à cette première salve la
deuxième suivra
pour les les premières questions si vous
voulez je suis longtemps que vous me
posez cette question mais je me demande
pourquoi vous la posez pas au ministère
la santé parce que c'était pas compliqué
de dire ce qu'il ya des gens qui adorent
faire des essais pourquoi ils ont pas
fait un essai dans le cycle à hockey
night raw piscine contre placebo je
tombe en bas dans globalement
globalement ce que vous voulez et c'est
une des reproches majeurs que j'ai fait
pour ce rapport ce ce conseil
scientifique c'est que tous les essais
avaient été décidés avant qu'ils aient
la moindre réunion du conseil
scientifique
il était question que du raid m6 viré du
lopinavir jamais l'hydroxyde routine qui
était le seul pour lequel on avait des
données préliminaires et qu' il n'y a
jamais eu d'organisation c'est c'est le
le comité scientifique n'a pas été c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles je me
suis mis en retrait de ce conseil
scientifique
ce conseil scientifique n'a jamais
piloté quoi que ce soit par cherche
locaux vides rien et donc qui sait qui a
apporté les données pour savoir que les
enfants n'étaient pas affectés c'est
nous toutes les données vous avez là ça
me fait ça m'amuse beaucoup que les gens
parlent de maintenant qui découvre que
les ct n'ont pas tous la même valeur
ça fait deux mois et demi qu'on l'a
écrit non quand même donc le débat il
est cette semaine
d'accord donc ça c'est des choses que le
pilotage de l'état aurait dû faire
aurait dû dire écoutez dites nous
quelles sont les limites du s'étaient
dites nous quelle est l'incidence des
différentes couches de populations dites
nous quelle est l'incidence chez les
patients symptomatiques et
asymptomatiques
ça c'est du pilotage d'accord et ce
pilotage
c'est le conseil scientifique et de
faire et je peux vous le dire j'ai écrit
très tôt en disant écoutez ce conseil
scientifique ne peut pas piloter une
recherche de crise
j'ai fait des propositions dont je me
suis au thé parce que je je je pensais
que je continue à penser que le plus
utile à faire ça sur place parce que les
décisions prendre tous les jours et que
je me sens à tort ou à raison capable de
le faire mais j'ai proposé des gens qui
faisait des centaines de milliers de pc
r je peux vous dire j'ai proposé le prof
de toulouse et celui de créteil
j'ai proposé des gens qui connaissaient
parfaitement la pharmacopée la
pharmacologie j'aurais jamais validé
l'ensicaen qui est un poison mortel
donc il y avait des gens qui étaient
capables
mener une véritable politique
scientifique ce conseil scientifique
n'était pas fait de gens qui étaient
capables de mener une politique
scientifique donc je le dis je exprimé
au président de la république et au
premier ministre je peux pas faire plus
ouais donc je regrette
effectivement il fallait faire une
politique très bien en disant écoutez
puisque c'est comme ça
vérifier ce que dit raul qu'il a
quelques éléments préliminaires commence
à les traiter comme ça fait long pour
répondre à votre question sur
l'efficacité
oui avant que ce soit interdit dans les
ehpad nous avons commencé à faire une
étude qui est là aussi
online que vous pouvez regarder dans les
ehpad sur lequel nous avons une baisse
de 50 % de la mortalité dans les ehpad
dans lequel on a pu traiter les gens par
rapport aux ans dont on n'a pas pu le
traité si on est passé de 27 à 14 %
c'est nos données aussi il faut le
regarder voilà puis il faut faire pareil
plutôt que dire elle n'est pas d'en
faire donc je je pense
il ya encore le temps et encore les
malades je pense que les gens qui se
posent la question moi je me pose pas la
question c'est pas moi qu'il faut la
poser la question et non seulement je me
la pose pas mais là non plus il faut pas
vivre dans des mythes truc il ya un
énorme papier qui est sorti aux états
unis gagnent journal of medecine qui
expliquent où est la place de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine d'après eux en
particulier au départ du fait de son
rôle contre les facteurs qui entraînent
la coagulation la coagulation est en
partie due à la sécrétion d'auto
anticorps ces anticorps anti
phospholipides qui sont les mêmes
anticorps qu'on trouve dans le lupus et
c'est la raison pourquoi on donne et
roxy que la routine dans le bus
donc tout ça sont des éléments là aussi
c'est intéressant de parler de science
donc ça c'est des éléments dont on à la
réalité maintenant vous parler de
communication en la communication
personnellement je pense j'ai toujours
pensé que la manière donc pour vous
voyez les choses on partait dans le mur
c'est ce que je pense donc moi je n'ai
fait que je n'ai jamais porté d'opinion
à part quand vous me le demandez dans
une situation officielle sur la
politique du gouvernement je n'ai porté
je n'ai fait que donner des chiffres et
les données que nous avions et que nous
étions les seuls à voir dans ce pays et
parfois les seuls à vendre d'accord je
les fais que ça donc
et vous les avez je suis désolé je
pensais qu on transmettra à tout le
monde vous allez jo sans limite quatre
pages de résultats
de ce que nous faisons et qui est
officiel on peut pas tricher avec sa
folie il ya qu elle est regardée
d'accord donc encore une fois équipe
usée
c'est vrai que cette même communication
que j'ai fait peut-être que vous trouvez
que nuisible mais il ya une quantité de
pays qu'ils ont utilisé cette
communication pour prendre des mesures
et pour prendre des mesures qui ont été
fonctionnelle moi j'ai des amis en
algérie je vous assure qu'ils testaient
plus que ce contest en france à ce
moment là d'accord parce que il avait
compris qu'il fallait tester donc il y
avait une faut pas me sortir
l'angleterre il il est sorti des papiers
aux états unis et en angleterre sur les
meilleurs journaux du monde où les gens
affirmé qu'ils avaient que un traitement
marcher ou pas marcher sans même avoir
fait un test biologique
donc il ya un phénomène de déroute qui
n'est pas que français il ya un vrai
phénomène de dante qui est écoutée ou
est-ce qu'on va où est ce qu'on va
et pour revenir je m'excuse pour les
chinois qui étaient posées pour une
autre question pourquoi moi je pense que
ça des chinois les chinois sont
actuellement les seuls compétiteurs que
nous ayons sur la science que nous
faisons sont tous en extrême-orient
c'est taiwan c'est la chine la corée du
sud c'est eux qui ont actuellement si
vous voulez savoir les infections
respiratoires des plus grandes séries du
monde sont toutes là ils ont pris une
approche extrêmement pragmatique
extrêmement moderne et nos concurrents
c'est à chaque fois je peux vous dire
des choses on essaie de faire
actuellement vers du séquençage direct
d'infection du cerveau une affection du
coeur tous contents parce qu'on a un
truc qu'on commence à écrire le papier
il ya un papier qui a été publiée avant
nous par des chinois dans un journal
dont vous avez jamais entendu parler
mais on est du coup on n'est pas les
premiers ça nous aide beaucoup
donc si vous voulez les chinois
actuellement ont une stratégie et que
moi j'ai vu kim a relancé un moment où
j'étais un peu découragé pour y achètent
quand j'ai vu ce qu'ils ont fait à
shanghai je vous assure fait une
délégation pour voir l'hôpital car à
côté de shanghai pour faire les maladies
infectieuses vous comprenez comment et
comment ils soignent un jeu pour dire il
ya un truc vous regardez vous voulez
vous n'avez même pas je m'excuse de dire
ça mais vous n'avez même pas
l'équivalent en maladies infectieuses de
ce qui est actuellement au sénégal au
mali ou au congo ici d'accord au sénégal
si vous allez à côté d'eux
bord du sénégal scheme ou aps je peux
vous dire payer par gilead d'ailleurs il
ya un bâtiment technologique dans lequel
il ya un niveau d'équipements de
diagnostic et de séquences qui est
absolument inouïe donc il ya une course
technologique qui s'est mise en avant
dans lequel il ya une partie ici pays
qui n'a pas suivi et l cette course
technologique
elle se passe en extrême orient voilà
pour ce qui se passe en afrique j'ai
fait c'est lui
pourquoi je le sais je vais je sais pas
prédire et deuxièmement je ne sais pas
pourquoi ce qui se passe en afrique qui
se passe en afrique alors il est
possible que en tout cas c'est ce que
disent beaucoup d'africains travail est
possible que le fait qu'ils prêtent de
la chloroquine systématiquement un joue
un rôle dans la diffusion de la maladie
c'est possible honnêtement je n'en sais
rien je ne miserais pas là dessus c'est
une constatation qu'on peut faire si on
généralise saâles usage ou pas c'est
comme ça concernant l'anxiété ça moi je
veux bien répondre à ça ça m'intéresse
beaucoup il ya peu vous admettrez que
l'anxiété les pas de mon côté g c'est
pas moi qui affole les populations non
seulement jean paul pas les populations
mais qui fusent et il n'y a pas vraiment
de raison d'être affolés et depuis le
début parce que je vous conseille de
regarder les données de l'ined d'accord
l'ined c'est l'institut national de la
démographie fait donc venir quelqu'un de
l'ined si vous voulez et vous dire à
quelle est actuellement la perte
d'espérance de vie pas la mortalité
parce que la mortalité à 85 ans c'est
pas la mortalité des accidents de la
route 1 donc la perte d'espérance de vie
n'est pas la même quand vous avez une
polypathologies que vous avez un cancer
métastasé ou quand vous avez 92 ans
n'est pas la même que quand vous avez 18
ans et que vous avez un accident de moto
c'est pas la même d'accord donc ça se
calcule l'espérance de vie est la perte
d'espérance de vie actuellement calculé
pour 2020 comparé à 2019 et les deux 02
ans elle est inférieure à celle de la
perte d'espérance de vie de 2015
d'accord c'est ça la situation donc
c'est ça c'est énorme
anxiété monstrueux c'est pas moi qui la
développe un mois et au contraire j'ai
toujours essayé d'être optimiste et au
contraire d'être du côté de dire écoutez
on n'est pas face à un drame absolument
insupportable
donc à la fin là aussi c'est pour ça que
c'est pas maintenant que ça va se régler
ça parte dans un débat que ça c'est que
ça va se régler avec les chiffres
enfin et on verra bien les chiffres et
on verra bien les chiffres donc moi je
les vois maintenant les chiffres je les
suis
est ce une manière très précise parce
que ça m'intéresse pas je vous dis je
suis empirique
donc ça m'intéresse de regard des
données chiffrées de les analyser de les
comprendre
et pourquoi la grippe qui a tellement tu
es dans l'année 2015 dont on est fichu
et pourquoi et qui a tué plus que ce que
ça va tuer cette année sauf s'il se
passe des choses absolument imprévisible
pour moi pourquoi baisse et parce que
d'un coup c'était la terreur que tout le
monde attendait qui allait arriver
c'est comme ça moi j'ai essayé là aussi
vous donner des données comparatives par
rapport au désastre du passé c'est pas
le même désir pour une simple raison
c'est que effectivement c'est pas le
même c'est pas le même âge qui meurt
donc jeudi à 50% des gens qui y sont
morts qui avait plus de 85 ans et 72 %
je crois qu'ils avaient plus de 80 ans
et donc dans les pays européens
plus de 90 % avaient plus de 60 ans donc
ce qui s'est passé c'est tous les ans
les gens qui sont sur un équilibre
précaire
les circonstances font que eh bien ces
gens qui ont un équilibre précaire donc
du côté du mauvais côté des choses et
donc c'est ça que nous voyons
essentiellement est là depuis les
épisodes ou jouets donnés tous les morts
qui sont produits depuis trois mois sur
ce ces données là voilà vous voyez donc
vous voyez les données d'âge
là ça chez nous je vous dis le plus bleu
mort le plus jeunes jusqu'à la côte d'or
avait 58 ans a malheureusement un homme
qui était dans un état absolument
épouvantable hockey qui est venue mourir
qui avait 54 ans qui a été refusée en
réanimation son état physiologique de
base était trop mauvais mais globalement
si vous voulez la perte et on n'a pas
calculé il ya des calculs très complet
qui s'appelle les dalits qui rajoute les
polypathologies à l'âge est la perte de
d'espérance de vie va être extrêmement
mineure donc c'est pas moi qui développe
l'enquêté je les dis encore la semaine
dernière
donc c'est pas moi qui développe
l'anxiété donc le l'interdiction
prescrire tout le monde c'est mon
opinion dessus si vous voulez mais là
encore je vois pas comment on aurait pu
avoir un débat serein quand en espace de
2 d'une demi journée
on sait le ministère et le msc mis à
dire on interdit partout l'hydroxyde
chloroquine parce que ça tue les gens
pour un papier qui a été retiré trois
semaines après parce que c'était une
bande de pieds nickelés qui avait écrit
ce truc dont personne ne savait d'où il
sortait donc c'est pas moi qui raconte
des bêtises quand même enfin au bout
d'un moment il faut revenir sur terre
c'est pas moi un carcan de bêtises qu'on
puisse penser qu'on puisse avoir la
pensée que ce truc est vrai quand on
parle d'un médicament qui a été donné à
deux milliards d'habitants ça veut dire
qu'au bout d'un moment on a les
déconnexions des deux parties de son
cerveau qui en a une qui est devenue
guerrière et symbolique
et puis l'autre qui rester pragmatique
ou pas mais c'est allé même parti
d'accord il ya quand même pour réussir à
vous faire avaler un truc comme ça il en
faut quand même hein je m'excuse mais
tout ceux qui ont cru un truc pareil
c'est quand même spectaculaire et
pourquoi les africains foutez de notre
gueule quand même c'est parce qu'ils
sont en train de nous dire qu'on attend
tous en train de mourir alors moi de la
chloroquine j'en bouffe et à l'âge de
deux ans en afrique on avait ça sur la
table tout le monde bouffer son comprimé
plus haut qui peut-être pour ça que je
crains pas la chloroquine donc le taux
attendez je vais tout marqué après
qu'est ce qui m'amuse 1 qu'est ce qui
marche pas dans notre système de santé
la hausse il faut regarder les données
chiffrées ce que je vous suggère il ya
un truc qui est très bien fait qu'ils
appellent l cette graine ce danger qui
est publié par l'otc de tous les ans
d'accord et c'est très bien il faut
regarder si je sais pas moi non plus les
chiffres faut les regarder et vous
regarderez quelles sont les différences
qui existent entre la france et les
autres pays en termes de mortalité en
termes de d'efforts financiers
donc il ya un effort financier
considérable de la france la france est
un des pays qui met le plus d'argent
possible dans la santé mais c'est un de
ceux qui a le moins de médecins via les
médecins les plus vieux et ça c'est
l'état qui a voulu sa limitation par le
numerus clausus pendant trente ans c'est
pas ce gouvernement c'est l'état qui a
voulu ça donc il a limité le nom
nombre de médecins d'une manière
drastique maintenant nous avons les
médecins les plus vieux d'europe fait
partie nous avons pas assez de médecins
les médecins hospitaliers gagnent moins
d'argent
c'est pas le cas des universitaires
double salle hermione bien notre vie
mais les médecins hospitaliers sont
moins bien payés en moyenne en france
que s'ils sont payés dans les autres
pays ocde que dans la moyenne de l'oscd
d'accord le niveau d'équipement en
france est inférieur à celui de la
moyenne des pays de l'osce et des eaux
des grands équipements d'accord et donc
vous avez la question vous avez la
réponse moi je veux pas débattre de sa
non plus il ya les chiffres il ya qu'à
les regarder
c'est c'est vous pouvez le télécharger
sur internet s'appelle human health and
glanz tous les angles ocde publiées les
données chiffrées qui leur sont
transmises comme pour la mortalité si
vous voulez savoir la mortalité vous
regardez oromo mouche désole un nom un
peu ridicule s'appelle oromo c'est
toutes les données de tous les pays
européens de mortalité au fil de l'eau
donc suffit de les regarder
est ce qu'il manque quelque chose sur
les mutations donc vous avez des
précisions demandées par les mutations
jeu bien sûr des les virus à tous mute
tout le temps c'est comme ça à chaque
fois on était une mutation c'est lié au
fait que vous faites une copie de
quelque chose et que vous faites une
copie à des erreurs d'accord mais les
copies de l'adn
il ya assez peu d'erreurs en moyenne il
ya une erreur par millions de copies
donc sur un million de base datés gc
dans la 1 million qui présentent une
mutation dans notre génome dans ceux des
bactéries la rn là c'est un virus à arn
il ya cent fois plus de mutations une
pour 10000 à peu près pour une pour 20
me ou 30 mx a été estimée s'estimer en
général et pour ce virus là ce estimé
être un pur temps mais où va donc ces
mutations l'a parfois sont des mutations
dont on voit pas qu'on appelle synonyme
c'est-à-dire qu'elle n'entraîne pas un
changement d'acides aminés ce qui ne
veut pas dire qu'elle ne change pas des
domaines de la science actuelle c'est
que parfois ça change pas d'acides
aminés mais ça change la soie appelle la
fitness est la capacité de se multiplier
du virus
parfois ça change en acides aminés
les mutations qu'on a observé il y en a
quelques-unes qui se trouve dans la
protéine spike dont vous avez beaucoup
entendu parler et qui est une des
molécules qui fermement la spécificité
c'est quand on a un virus il ya des ddd
mutation qui se trouve dans la
nucléocapside c'est à dire dans le
premier entier et c'est les deux grands
antigènes si vous voulez que nous
reconnaissons quand on a une réponse
immunitaire c'est un la numéro
nucléocapside mais qui est qui et qui a
beaucoup de points communs avec tous les
autres coronavirus c'est pour ça qu'il
ya des réactions croisées peut-être dé
protection croisée
et puis la protéine spike qui est
relativement spécifiques
là aussi tentant dans lequel on a une
mutation donc ce que nous ont conté ce
qu'on regarde c'est le nombre de
mutations qui sont survenues par rapport
à virus souche d'accord donc bien sûr il
ya des mutations mais globalement on
avait l'habitude qui est en moyenne 9 à
10 mutation par rapport au virus souche
pendant la première partie c'est à dire
qu'ils allaient dans les souches que
nous nous avons eu entre mars et mai
d'accord dans cette deuxième partie le
nombre de mutations par souche par
rapport à la mutation mère pas par
rapport à la souche mère est dix fois
plus grande il ya beaucoup plus de
mutations que ce que nous envoyons avant
et ça il ya plusieurs clauses qui sont
comme ça qu'ils ont donc une distance
on mesure la distance en regardant le
nombre de mutations par rapport à la
souche primaires si vous voulez donc ça
veut dire que la distance par rapport à
ce jeu primé avec plus importante
maintenant que ce qu'elle était avant
merci pour ces précisions va continuer
et si on d'être concis dans les
questions et les réponses néanmoins il
ya une réponse que vous n'avez pas fait
c'est concernant les préconisations du
comité scientifique qui n'était pas
suivie par le gouvernement si vous avez
en quelques mots quelque chose à dire
pour répondre à roger karoutchi
je me suis appliquée l'était il ya eu
des quelques recommandations qui n'ont
pas été suivis on l'avait vu au moment
des écoles on l'a vu encore dernièrement
où la question est extrêmement sa mesure
le conseil scientifique affirme faire
firme est normalement l'autorité de
référence qui donne des avis parfois le
gouvernement suit parfois le
gouvernement ne suis pas est ce que
aujourd'hui l'existence du conseil
scientifique a encore une vraie valeur
dans le débat rapidement je suis
d'accord pour le fait que le
gouvernement décide de suivre tu as su
parce que la responsabilité politique
on voit bien ce pont stabilité politique
la première fois donc la responsabilité
politique c'est la responsabilité
politique c'est celui qui a la
responsabilité qui décide c'est comme ça
que je vois les choses
après il a des conseils que ces conseils
soient personnellement je n'étais pas
d'avis que les conseils du conseil
scientifique son public
je pense qu'il aurait dû avoir un
conseil du président ou un conseil du
ministre que ça se décide au tour de
ministres et que le ministre disent
écoutez voilà j'ai écouté voilà mon
opinion est que chaud sorti comme ça
c'était mon avis et jusqu'à présent
c'est toujours comme ça que ça s'est
passé mais la composition du conseil
dans une partie qui était stratégique
à mon sens n'était pas bonne parce que
c'était le dérivé de reacting qui était
le groupe qui avait été mis en place par
les serbes ça c'est mon opinion
alors on y va toujours le plus court
possible il nous reste un bon quart
d'heure petit angèle préville merci
monsieur le président
donc mon professeur j'ai d'abord une
question qui vient à la suite de ce que
vous venez de nous dire sur la mutation
du virus donc il y à des mutations mais
je pense que dans l'inconscient
collectif
on parle de mutation quand le virus
devient beaucoup plus dangereux pas on
sous-entend que alors est ce que dans
tous ces mutations est ce que dans l'eau
cure les occurrences vous voyez arriver
par les connaissances que vous avez qu à
un moment donné il risque de devenir
beaucoup plus virulent
c'est à dire beaucoup plus dangereux
deuxième question alors sur les essais
alors vous avez évoqué les raisons
éthiques voire morale qui font que vous
n'avez pas voulu avoir recours à des
placebos parce qu'on était en k2 dans un
état de crise avec une maladie très
grave puisqu'elle peut provoquer des
décès alors est ce que il vous semble
est ce qu'il ya des choses là dessus sur
le fait que quand on est en crise
on fait pas de décès visiblement parce
que effectivement les arguments que vous
avez peuvent s'entendre
et puis parce que on a souvent dit que
l'effet placebo c'est l homéopathie et
cetera donc pour des choses pour des de
la petite bobologie peut-être alors
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
l'effet placebo parce que peut-être ce
sera intéressant de savoir après une
autre question
vous avez évoqué la création de centres
anti infectieux est ce que votre route
est-ce que vous sous-entendez que votre
structure à marseille en est une
est-ce qu'il y en a d'autres et soeurs
avant toute chose je voudrais quand même
exprimé un regret effectivement de ne
pas pouvoir avoir avoir été auditionné
vos propos vous avez exprimé le fait de
dire je ne comprends pas je comprends
pas ce qui s'est passé pourquoi ça s'est
emballée médiatiquement quand j'ai parlé
etc
c'est ce que vous avez dit en début de
vos propos liminaire c'est ça que je
parte pas voilà moi je voudrais vous
dire que je vais vous donner mon
expérience personnelle je vous dire que
je pense comprendre
moi je n'ai pas compris par contre le
premier matin ou en fait vous êtes
intervenu sur les ondes nom de radio où
vous avez affirmé à ce moment là
effectivement l'effet positif la
chloroquine et avoir suscité un espoir
en fait important chez des habitants des
français qui étaient à ce moment-là
inquiet en pleine période d'épidémie est
dans une situation qu'elle c'est une
situation quasi catastrophique de notre
pays
donc votre en fait votre expression
publique de votre statut de chercheur
reconnu et de renom a effectivement
suscité un grand espoir
or ne pensez vous pas qu'à ce moment là
alors vous
d'ethnie journalistes ni politique vous
êtes vraiment un scientifique que l'on
écoute reconnu et sur lequel on pose en
fait nos oreilles et notre conviction
ne pensez vous pas que vos paroles à ce
moment là n'aurait pas dû ted être
peut-être différé est ce que vous pensez
pas que les études auraient dû être un
peu plus avancé des résultats plus
concrets avant avant de voilà d'aller
confirmer ou infirmer des choses comme
ça qui ont été prises chez une partie de
nos concitoyens comme d'un peu d'argent
comptant et je pense que ça a été le
début de la fracture d'opinion dans
notre pays est un espèce de clan en fait
dans ce pays les pour et les contre le
professeur à août alors que le débat et
je le conçois n'est absolument pas là
donc c'est un petit peu est-ce qu'il ya
pas une forme d' imprudence ou est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous pensé que c'était la
bonne solution et que vous
recommenceriez avec l'expérience ce même
cette même expression publique et après
j'avais deux autres questions mais ça a
été répondu pourquoi ne pas avoir fait
les études en double aveugle mais ça
rejoint la première et enfin la question
de la mutation est ce que la mutation
que vous exprimer en laboratoire est une
mutation clinique avec plus grand plus
de gravité ou au contraire une gravité
moins importante
et puis un changement de cible voilà
mais la question était posée donc je
n'irai pas plus loin je vous remercie
hier si merci céline boulay merci
messieurs président j'étais vraiment
venu à cette audition moi aussi pour
poser la question qui rejoint celle de
ce levier vers millet de ma collègue à
l'instant qui était de dire que dit de
vous finalement cette sur médiatisation
et cet emballement médiatique
et qu'est ce que ça dit du débat
contradictoire en france et de la
démocratie sanitaire alors vous avez
partiellement répondu et notamment
répondu avec une certaine modestie je le
trouve en tout cas personnellement tout
au long de cette audition en faisant
l'apologie de l'empirisme et en disant
on attend un peu on va comparer les
chiffres et là on verra qui aura raison
il vous avait parlé de pionnier en la
matière en tout cas puisqu'il s'agit
souvent hors de nos auditions de retour
d'expérience je note qu'il ya une grande
confusion qui règne dans la tête de nos
compatriotes français puisque en
attendant les chiffres est de savoir qui
aura raison le retour d'expérience qui
était censée rassurer tout le monde en
disant on a vécu une première crise
majeure
on saura qu'on saura gérer un deuxième
rebond
pour l'instant créer cette confusion est
peut-être cette inquiétude et on le voit
quand on interroge sur la mutation du
virus en fait on a des réponses qui sont
totalement contradictoires
donc moi j'ai maintenant 3 toute petite
question précise la première on a
beaucoup parlé donc de mutation du virus
mais est ce que vous seriez nous dire où
en est l'état de nos connaissances quant
aux malades qui ont été symptomatique
vous disiez très justement qu'au début
il y avait peu de paix de dano semis et
d'agouazi il y en a eu beaucoup plus
après est ce que ces malades là peut
avoir une évolution de leurs séquelles
par exemple atteint avis ou durablement
dans leur père danos me aggasy ça c'est
une première car la deuxième je ne crois
pas que vous ayez répondu à notre
collègue rapporteur bernard jomier quand
vous avez dit de manière très forte
qu'en matière infectieuses il y avait
une destruction physique de
l'organisation des maladies infectieuses
qui est à l'origine de cette d'esprit
destruction et pourquoi
enfin dernière question rapide lorsque
vous aviez été interrogé récemment pour
savoir ce que vous pensiez du port du
masque généralisée vous avez répondu je
ne fais pas de politique
et vous avez une phrase tout à l'heure
que j'ai trouvé forte aussi en dix ans
et l'intendance qui suit la décision
or on en a parlé ce matin avec le comité
scientifique on a eu l'impression qu'au
début il n'y avait pas de port du masque
généralisée parce qu'il y avait pas de
masque maintenant il l'est parce qu'on
est des masques et je voulais savoir ce
que vous pensez de ça je vous remercie
olivier paccaud merci monsieur le
président professeur ce matin
effectivement les membres du conseil
scientifique comme l'a dit olivier henno
ont évoqué l'impréparation de notre
système médical pour faire face vous
même
ça vient d'être redit dans votre propos
liminaire vous avez pointé du doigt la
désorganisation voire la déstructuration
programmée entre guillemets de du
système de recherche épidémiologique de
recherche
est ce qu'en fait c'est pas plutôt une
combinaison des deux qui a abouti à ce
que l'on peut considérer quand même
comme une hécatombe alors les chiffres
sont plus ou moins variable
vous avez dit vous même tout à l'heure
que c'était peut-être pas si dramatique
que ça par rapport à aux résultats 2015
de la grippe de 2015
je suis pas sûre que
ça ne soit pas dramatique quand même par
contre ma question elle va traiter de
vous avez évoqué le benchmarking les
résultats français sont loin d'être
brillant il ya pire
il ya mieux ce matin on avait eu
quelques cas de l'allemagne a quand même
dix mille morts mais il y a quelques
jours dans cette même dans ce même
hémicycle nous avons reçu les
ambassadeurs de corée du sud de taïwan
et on a eu des chiffres qui sont tout à
fait éloquent sept morts à taïwan 346 en
corée du sud
alors ma question c'est on a vu ce
qu'ils ont fait à eux vous d'après vous
quand on veut éteindre un incendie
épidémiologique éviter qu'ils se
transforment en brasier
qu'est ce que l'on doit faire
immédiatement quand on a pas de vaccin
si monsieur le président un bar et joris
diversi mais simplement de questions
vous avez dit tout à l'heure c'est le
temps qui fait le tri et vous avez cité
beaucoup de papier c'est vrai que
vis-à-vis nous déjà mais je pense les
français c'est difficile quand même à
comprendre parce qu'on sait qu'il ya des
papiers vous en avez d'ailleurs vous
l'avez dénonce et qui sont
malheureusement publiés et qu'ils sont
faux et je pense que la confusion non
pas se parler ma collègue est quand même
extrêmement importante et que même s'il
faut attendre le temps c'est vrai que la
science a quand même parlé sur un
certain nombre de choses et comme
bernard jomier et d'autres moi je
regrette qu'il n'y ait pas de
confrontation parce que comme on n'a pas
de confrontation entre chercheurs
on vous voit dans les médias les uns se
re pour les autres contre et c'est vrai
que ce matin on parlait peut-être au
lieu du conseil scientifique est
peut-être une agence dédiée aux crises
et pas seulement d'ailleurs avec des
scientifiques mais aussi avec des
chercheurs des sciences humaines et
sociales
et s'il y avait peut-être cette agence
en france peut-être que ça permettrait
aussi aux français de mieux comprendre
de moins avoir peur et je voudrais avoir
un peu votre avis là dessus et puis la
dernière
la deuxième question ça rejoint
d'ailleurs mon collègue david assouline
c'est on n'a pas parlé du vaccin
quelle est votre position aujourd'hui
sur le vaccin merci david assouline où
la question est posée par ces jeux le
souffle est une question qui me venait à
l'esprit mais non j'ai deux questions
brèves
la première c'est je reste perplexe
parce que finalement la polémique qui
enfle qui a fait connaître au grand
public
votre non monsieur le professeur vous
étiez déjà très connue des milieux qui
devait l'être qui était professionnel
c'est votre traitement
je ne comprends pas que six mois après
on en reste à
il ya les pour et les contre moi je pose
la question
six mois après même quand ça n'a pas été
autorisé à la prescription
je connais du monde qui parce qu'il n'y
avait pas de traitement se sont rués est
une façon ou d'une autre par ce
médicament
il n'y a pas eu de résultats aujourd'hui
on vous avez fait vos hôtes est sur une
centaine de personnes vous défendez qu'
il y avait des améliorations mais
maintenant c'est moi après c'est plus un
débat il ya rien de probant enfin je
comprends pas ou sinon qu'est ce que
vous dites à monsieur macron vous lui
dites que il interdit et à tous ces
scientifiques à tous ces gens notamment
le comité scientifique qui disent que ce
n'est pas efficace faut aller au bout
vous les accusez de refuser un
médicament qui empêcherait des cas de
s'aggraver de soigner des français c'est
cessa six mois après c'est pas un débat
des pour et des contres moi j'ai
beaucoup de critiques je suis critique
comme tout le monde
donc je prends je gobe pas tout ce que
nous dit le gouvernement les gens les
scientifiques
mais là à moins de me dire bien complot
qu'on veut que des français ne se soigne
pas et meurt je ne comprend pas la
nature du débat et ma conclusion en
question parce que la seule façon pour
moi de le comprendre c'est que derrière
le scientifique que vous êtes le
pragmatique que vous êtes
il ya peut-être quelque chose qui vient
troubler c'est l'idéologie
qu'avez-vous de commun pour faire
tribune commune bientôt avec monsieur
onfray philosophe
qu'avez-vous de commun à dire ou sur la
pandémie
poux sur la société je ne comprends pas
merci jean sol excuses
président monsieur le professeur j'ai
plusieurs questions comme l'ensemble des
français j'ai été confinés que
pensez-vous du confinement automne mise
en place dans notre pays
aurait-il pu être évité à l'instar
d'autres pays qui nous ont présenté
récemment mais leurs résultats
quel est votre avis sur la doctrine en
matière de masques qui s'est fait à
géométrie variable faut-il le
reconnaître qui est encore floue
aujourd'hui et dont certains remettent
en cause le degré de filtration dans
certains contextes
pensez vous que les moyens en matière de
recherche sont au rendez vous en france
je ne pense pas vous nous l'aviez déjà
exprimé lorsque nous vous nous avions
auditionnés vous savez cité l'exemple
tout à l'heure du nombre de scanners et
enfin est il possible selon vous de
raccourcir les délais pour réaliser les
tests aujourd'hui et surtout pour un
obtenir les résultats dans un délai
raisonnable merci merci avait coûté dix
minutes très bien et dix minutes pour
tout ça donc s'il vous plaît le premier
point qui est qu'elle soit placée volet
sport vous savez c'est un vrai point
c'est une occasion je peut se discuter
qu'elle confesse j'ai diffusé aussi
bernard henri lévy 2-2 de dire que c'est
dramatique d'apporter de l'espoir
je suis pas d'accord je pense est
dramatique d'apporter du désespoir
je pense et je continue à le penser je
continuerai à le penser car et l'effet
placebo c'est effectivement d'abord ça
commence par apporter l'espoir
donc il ya eu négligence de la
connaissance de l'effet placebo
scientifique sepehri fientes l'effet
placebo c'est un effet biologique que
l'on peut parfaitement noté avec les
moyens actuels de de radiologie qui
permet de voir qu'il ya des zones qui
sont éteintes ou qui sont ali mais quand
on vous savez quand on vous dit aux gens
qu'ils vont mourir on voit les zones ces
thèmes dans le fond ça s'appelle l'effet
nocebo et donc quand on dit ça tous les
soirs à la télévision ce qu'on fait on
crée de l'effet nocebo qui est visible
radiologiquement quand on donne de
l'espoir aux gens y compris avec l'effet
placebo on voit les zones où ça se fixe
et sa 6e
au même endroit que benzodiazépines
c'est à dire ça calme les gens donc ça
exclut c'est de la science encore la
deuxième chose c'est que effectivement
je suis un plus qui posé la question
mais on peut rebondir dessus il ya une
vraie question sur les séquelles
malheureusement on a commencé à
travailler dessus on a fait un papier
dessus qui est très impressionnant qui
montre que les zones il ya des zones qui
ont un hypométabolisme derrière le bulbe
olfactif qui semble persister on sait
pas combien de temps elles vont
persister on sait pas ce qu'il guérira
et on sait pas ce qu'ils en protège mais
oui il ya des séquelles cérébrales
pendant un certain temps je sais pas
combien de temps plus que de séquelles
pulmonaires que l'on redoutait beaucoup
redoutaient beaucoup qui est beaucoup de
fibres hozjan a relativement peu mais il
ya des extinctions du métabolisme
cérébral qui est qu'on perçoit et on n'a
pas suffisamment de recul pour savoir
combien de temps ça va durer
le lead et j'y peux rien je vous leur
direz vous pensez vraiment que le
l'histoire de hydroxy chloroquine si
vous voulez et l'histoire de ce débat
est un débat franco français avec mon
milieu et c'est pas vrai c'est
simplement pas vrai vous voyez ça dit si
c'est pas vrai c'est un débat mondial
vous vous rendez bien compte qu'on
comment vous pouvez penser qu'une bande
de polichinelle a publiée dans le new
england journal médecine et dans l'aude
sept si on était pas on à être pas perdu
toute notion de base pour publier des
choses pareilles qui ont été rétractées
dans les trois mois je n'ai jamais vu ça
de toute l'histoire la médecine j'ai
jamais vu ça c'est pas moi qui ai fait
ça c'est pas moi qui ai déterminer sa
donc arretez de croire c'est une
histoire franco-française est un
phénomène beaucoup plus puissants que ça
qui est extrêmement qui est
international qui touche
il ya une partie qui a réagi d'une
certaine manière qui est l'europe de
l'ouest et une partie des états unis qui
a d'ailleurs les plus mauvais chiffres
mondiaux de gestion de la crise qui a
géré d'une certaine manière en courant
après deux molécules nouvelles fait à
nouveau par des laboratoires qui
maintenant cours d'une certaine autre
manière après après la vaccination il ya
une autre partie qui était une partie de
gestion extrêmement pragmatique y
compris si vous avez vu les coréens
c'est un pragmatisme qui est totale donc
il y as we une manière pragmatique de
gérer chose qui est de détecter 10
et il ya des gens qui a des pays dans
lequel on a réquisitionné des hôtels
pour y mettre les gens qui étaient
positifs tant qu'ils étaient positifs de
manière à faire ce qu'on faisait avant
avec le lazaret et non pas faire ce
qu'on a fait avec le confinement qui est
la quarantaine
donc c'est des natures différentes ce
qui s'est passé dans la destruction et
la direction je suis d'accord que ça n'a
pas été volontaire il s'est trouvé que
il ya eu une époque qui est une époque
paradoxale qui était juste avant
l'épidémie de sida les gens disaient
mahdi infectieuses c'est terminé donc il
y avait à paris à l'hôpital claude
bernard les gens ont travaillé sur les
maladies infectieuses et assez de
manière assez extraordinaire c'est au
moment où le sida est arrivé on a fermé
claude bernard c'est en effet fermer
l'endroit dans lequel on pouvait
investir massivement pour pouvoir lutter
contre les nouvelles épidémies qui
arrive et ça a été la pire épidémie du
20e siècle la sueur et donc il ya une
vraie il ya une vraie question de remise
en cause est ce que vous vous considérez
comme est incompréhensible moi je
comprends bien c'est que quand les gens
ont pris le problème en main y compris
d'ailleurs ont pris une direction c'est
très très difficile de sortir du sentier
dans lequel on est rentré c'est très
compliqué de dire écoutez on s'est
trompé finalement c'est pas comme ça
qu'il fallait faire c'est compliqué pour
chacun d'entre nous mais c'est compliqué
pour le ministre c'est compliqué pour le
président la république c'est compliqué
pour des frais si et ses prolongements
compliqué pour moi même si je suis pas
lucide de ce point de vue-là parce que
je le vois pas donc c'est sais c'est pas
encore une fois c'est ce qui s'est passé
et quand vous me dites et détient
comment ça se traduit
moi je trouve étonnant que ce soit que
les consignes de maladies infectieuses
dans l'assistance publique de paris soit
donnée par le directeur sens unique de
paris à marseille les consignes de mal à
dire qu'ils ne sont pas donnés par le dg
de sang celui de marseille et je peux
vous dire que quand j'étais jeune
titulaire de chaire d'affection c'est
lui qui disent il ajouté ça qu'il faut
faire
c'était pas le dg de la cie dans celui
de paris cécile c'est étrange non enfin
j'en sais rien un truc de professionnels
la médecine je m'excuse donc il y a une
grille question bon je vous dis c'est ce
que je pense je pensais moi je pense
qu'il va aller faire un affectio paul
necker pasteur je l'écris en 2003 mais à
necker à pasteur faire un bâtiment pour
les maladies infectieuses à necker soit
juste à côté de pasteur
que les gens au travail tu es une
antenne de la nds et maintenant santé
publique et là il y aurait quelque chose
qui pourrait avoir une taille mondiale
où il y aurait des interlocuteurs soient
capables de tout faire ça c'était
raisonnable
c'est ce que je pensais à l'époque et je
pense encore maintenant peut-être parce
que je suis incapable de changer d'avis
c'est possible est ce que j'ai oublié
quelque chose vous posez la question de
dudu du confinement et du masque cetc
des questions ceux qui sont extrêmement
ok il est extrêmement difficile de
répondre
il ya des gens qui commencent à étudier
ça à faire des études comparatives et
même ses études comparatives elles sont
difficiles à analyser parce que les
comportements sociaux dans les
différents pays sont pas les mêmes donc
le comportement social en italie et en
suède sait pas exactement même en
particulier dans l'est les contacts
sociaux sont pas les mêmes et donc de
comparer l'effet du confinement sur
l'efficacité des mesures c'est quelque
chose qui est très complexe et moi je
pensais donc c'est ce que j'ai dit quand
j'ai rencontré le président je le dis
moi il faut prendre
je pense que le rôle du politique c'est
prend toutes les mesures pour éviter
l'affolement la peur la peur est
terrible il faut éviter l'affolement
mais si ça donne l'effet inverse si vous
voulez alors c'est pas fonctionnel parce
que le confinement ça ça a été analysé
en italie en espagne sur des milliers de
tests de donneurs de sang 1
le confinement n'a pas protégé les gens
individuellement du risque d'infection
c'est à dire que les gens qui n'étaient
pas pour des raisons professionnelles à
part le métier de santé qui n'était pas
confinée tu es plutôt moins positif que
les gens ont confiné
donc ya pas de substrats scientifique
individuel ce qui ne veut pas dire que
ce ne soit pas un choix de société à un
moment donné de dire écoutez plutôt que
tout le monde soit folle et s'inquiète
émigrent si vous voulez il vaut mieux
les confiner donc je sais pas répondre à
ça et pour le masquer c'est pareil c'est
pas une vérité scientifique brutale il
ya une vérité scientifique brutale c'est
que quand vous êtes dans le personnel de
soins canton étant donné qu'on est à 30
40 centimètres des gens le risque de
contamination est plus important c'est
évident ça a été il a été démontré